I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. We're gonna booze it up today. It is the booze cruise episode, everybody. Are you running a party? Season two, episode 11, written by Greg Daniels, directed by Ken Quapas. Angela's been on a booze cruise. In the Cayman Islands. Ooh, I've been on a booze cruise of Lake Ozark, Missouri. That's, that's the one I want to go on. Oh yeah, live band, all of it. Very
我是詹娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来《办公室》终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女郎们。我们今天要开怀畅饮了。大家注意，这就是“酒水游轮”那一集。你们在开派对吗？第二季第11集，格雷格·丹尼尔斯编剧，肯·夸帕斯导演。安吉拉去过酒水游轮。在开曼群岛。哦，我去过密苏里州奥沙克湖的酒水游轮。那，那才是我最想去的。哦对，有现场乐队，应有尽有。非常
similar. Okay, let's get into this. Let's get into it. I will start with a summary. I feel like this episode doesn't need it, but I'm gonna give one anyway. Michael takes the office on a booze cruise of Lake Wallin Paw Pack. So corporate won't pay for any more parties, but Michael found a loophole. As long as he calls it a leadership training exercise, then corporate will endorse it. So that's what he does, but it's really just an excuse for a party. Michael loves a party. All right, let's jump in with fast fact number one. Booze cruise was the first episode to air on Thursday nights. Yeah, this was a huge deal. This was a huge deal for us. Must-See TV lineup. We were so giddy about this. We
相似。好了，我们进入正题吧。我们开始吧。我先做一个总结。我觉得这一集其实不需要总结，但我还是要做一个。迈克尔带着办公室员工去瓦伦帕普克湖进行了一次酒水游轮之旅。因为总公司不愿再为任何派对买单了，但迈克尔找到了一个漏洞。只要他把这称作领导力培训活动，总公司就会批准。所以他就是这么做的，但这其实只是开派对的借口。迈克尔最喜欢开派对。好了，让我们直接来看趣味冷知识第一条。“酒水游轮”是第一集在周四晚上播出的剧集。是的，这可是件大事。这对我们来说是件大事。黄金必看电视档。我们当时兴奋得不得了。我们
were so excited. I wrote a whole MySpace blog about it. I was so happy. I did too. Yeah. Announcing our move to Thursday nights. Cause I don't know if people know, but we started on Tuesday nights at 9 30. And now we were moving to the Thursday must-see TV lineup. This was a coveted time slot. You guys, it's where friends was. It was a big, big deal. It still is. It's still their big night of comedy. So we felt like we'd really made it. And also this is a fan question from Sean Anaya. In episode two of the podcast, Angela mentioned that she and the other supporting cast members became series regulars during the booze cruise. Yes. Angela, how did that feel? It was such an exciting time, Jenna,
超级兴奋。我还为此写了一篇MySpace博客。我太高兴了。我也是。是的。宣布我们转战周四晚间档。因为我不知道大家知不知道，我们最初是在周二晚上9点半播出的。现在我们要转到周四黄金必看电视档了。这是一个让人垂涎的时段。伙计们，那是《老朋友》播出的时间。这可是一件天大的事。现在依然如此。这依然是他们重磅的喜剧之夜。所以我们觉得自己真的成功了。另外，这是一个来自肖恩·阿纳亚的粉丝提问。在播客第二集里，安吉拉提到她和其他配角演员在“酒水游轮”期间成为了常驻演员。是的。安吉拉，当时感觉怎么样？这是一个让人无比激动的时刻，詹娜，
because like, you know, our agents called us and said, Hey, they want to make you series regulars. We were all so, so excited. It also meant that maybe we wouldn't get fired. Now, did that happen in the middle of filming booze cruise or at the beginning? What was the timing in the middle? We were on the boat. I remember we were on the boat when I got the call saying that NBC would like for you to be series regulars and you're going to have like an extended contract. You're not going to be a week to week day player. Oh my gosh. We were all talking. We were also excited. The supporting cast, you and I, um, we had a break where we got to go off the boat, but we're standing right by the boat, Jenna. We're right by the boat.
因为你知道，我们的经纪人打电话给我们说，嘿，他们想让你们成为常驻演员。我们当时都兴奋极了。这也意味着我们可能不会被炒鱿鱼了。那么，这发生是在拍摄“酒水游轮”的中途还是刚开始？时间点是什么时候？是在中途。我们当时在船上。我记得当我在船上接到电话，说NBC希望你们成为常驻演员，而且你们将获得长期合同时，我们正在船上。你们不再是那种按周拿酬劳的特约演员了。天哪。我们当时都在谈论。我们都太兴奋了。配角演员们，你和我，嗯，我们有个休息时间，可以下船，但我们就站在船边，詹娜。我们就站在船边。
And I gave Oscar Nunez my camera and I said, Oscar, I want you to capture this moment. You and I had been jumping up and down, holding hands, screaming because we were so excited. And you have that photo. I have the photo and you and I look insane because we're, we're tired and we're mid jumping up and air holding hands like two school girls. And Oscar was like, Oh, you two are so silly. And he gave us a big hug, but, um, this was job security. Yeah. And this, yes, this was like, we all knew now one, our show must be doing well because now they're going to pay us all to be here all the time. Yeah. And, and then we knew we had a job special, special. Things are starting to turn now. We've been talking
我把我的相机递给奥斯卡·努涅斯，我说，奥斯卡，我希望你捕捉下这个时刻。你和我当时一直在上下蹦跳，手拉着手，尖叫着，因为我们太兴奋了。你还有那张照片。我有那张照片，照片里的你和我都看起来像疯子一样，因为我们太累了，而且正处在半空中跳跃、手拉着手像两个女学生一样的状态。奥斯卡当时就说，噢，你们两个太傻了。然后他给了我们一个大大的拥抱，但是，嗯，这就是饭碗的保障。没错，是的，这就像是，我们现在都知道第一，我们的节目肯定很受欢迎，因为现在他们要付钱让我们一直都在这里了。是的，而且，然后我们就知道我们有了一份特别的、特别的工作。情况开始好转了。我们之前一直在讨论
about how we were really wondering week to week if we had jobs and now we're starting to feel like, Oh, we're on a TV show that's going to keep coming back. Now we still haven't been picked up for season three yet, but we know, okay, we at least have a job for like another 13 weeks at this point. Yeah. This was the most job security any of us had had since the beginning of the show. Oh yeah. Yeah. For sure. For sure. All right. Fast fact number two, let's talk about our guest stars. Big, big guest stars. First up, this is the third and final appearance of Amy Adams as Katie. Now I went back and I was looking at the timeline. She had not yet been nominated for her Academy Award for Junebug. That happened
我们每周都在担心自己有没有工作，而现在我们开始觉得，噢，我们正在拍一部会一直播下去的电视剧。虽然我们当时还没续签第三季，但我们知道，好吧，至少目前我们还有大约13周的工作。是的。这是自节目开播以来，我们所有人的工作最稳固的一次。哦，是的。是的。肯定的。肯定的。好的，趣味冷知识第二条，我们来聊聊客串明星。大牌大牌的客串明星。首先，这是艾米·亚当斯第三次也是最后一次饰演凯蒂。现在我回过头去查看了时间线。她当时还没有因为《六月虫》获得奥斯卡提名。那是在
just a couple weeks after we finished filming this episode, but there was a ton of buzz. There was a lot of buzz that she was going to be an Oscar contender. And it was just so wonderful knowing her the way we did at this point and knowing that she had just been a hard working actress. Some things had gone her way. Some things hadn't. And to just sort of see this electricity around her and she is just such a humble, sweet, kind person. You just can't help but root for her. And I remember being so happy for her and hopeful. I was seated next to her for pretty much most of the work in this episode. And we just became such good friends doing this. We shared so much about our lives and our hopes and our
我们完成这集拍摄后几周才发生的，但当时已经有很多轰动效应了。有很多人猜测她会成为奥斯卡奖的有力竞争者。以我们当时那种方式了解她，知道她一直以来只是一个努力工作的女演员，这种感觉真的很奇妙。有些事情对她有利，有些则不然。看到她周围环绕着这种充满活力的氛围，而且她又是如此谦逊、甜美、善良的一个人，你真的忍不住想为她加油。我记得当时为她感到非常高兴，也充满希望。在这集的拍摄中，我差不多大部分时间都坐在她旁边。我们在拍摄过程中成为了很好的朋友。我们分享了许多关于彼此生活、希望以及
dreams. And she was just a very open, warm, generous person. And then, you know, this boat was no frills. No frills. No frills on this boat. Okay. Yeah. We were just sleeping on those benches between takes and she was all in. Another big guest star from this episode is Rob Riggle as Captain Jack. Riggs. All right. So a few facts about Rob in case people don't know. He is a real Marine Corps veteran. He joined the Marines in 1990 with the intention of becoming a naval aviator. But then he left to pursue comedy. Yeah. Comedy. Yeah. But he stayed a member of the Marine Corps Reserves until he retired in 2013 after 23 years of service. I mean, this is he's the real deal. He is the real deal. And the man has such
梦想的事情。她真的是一个非常坦诚、热情、慷慨的人。然后呢，你知道，这艘船没有什么高级设施。没有高级设施。这艘船上没有任何高级设施。好吧。是的。我们在拍摄间隙就睡在那些长凳上，而她完全融入其中。这一集的另一位大牌客串明星是饰演杰克船长的罗布·里格尔。里格斯。好的。关于罗布的一些冷知识，以防大家不知道。他是一名真正的美国海军陆战队退伍军人。他于1990年加入海军陆战队，最初的打算是成为一名海军飞行员。但后来他离开去追求喜剧事业。对。喜剧。对。但他一直保留着海军陆战队预备役的身份，直到2013年退役，结束了23年的服役生涯。我的意思是，他是来真的。他是玩真的。而且这个人心
a heart for service. You do the softball game with him. I do. He's one of the people. He's one of the people for Children's Mercy Hospital. And Rob is just an inspiration to me. Well, you guys out there might recognize him also from SNL or from The Daily Show where he played their military correspondent or from like a gazillion movies, including Furry Vengeance with Angela Kinsey. He was in Furry Vengeance. And then you won't recognize him from a pilot he and I did called the Gabriel's on Fox that never saw the light of day where we played husband and wife. We had so much fun. I keep telling him, I'm like, Rob, someday we're going to get to play husband and wife again. Oh, I would love to see that. You guys would
怀大爱，热心公益。你跟他一起打过垒球。我打过。他是其中一员。他是儿童慈悲医院的志同道合者之一。罗布对我的激励非常大。好吧，各位听众可能也会在《周六夜现场》或《每日秀》里认出他，他在那里扮演过军事记者，或者在无数电影里见过他，包括和安吉拉·金西合作的《毛茸茸的复仇》。他出演了《毛茸茸的复仇》。然后你们绝不会在我和他一起拍过的一部名为福克斯电视台的《加布里埃尔一家》的试播集里认出他，那部剧从未问世，我们在其中扮演夫妻。我们当时玩得太开心了。我一直跟他说，我说，罗布，总有一天我们还得演夫妻。哦，我很想看到那个。你们俩一定
be great. Yeah. So you know him. You're friends with him. Yes, we are pals. So I called him yesterday and he's like the busiest guy ever. I was like, Rob, where are you? Are you in Los Angeles? Because the last time I talked to him, he was in Scotland. Oh, he's like doing some really fun stuff. But I talked to him and I was like, Rob, what do you remember about Captain Jack and the whole booze cruise episode? And this is what he said. Okay. He said, well, Ang, on a personal level, it was one of the first jobs I had after leaving Saturday Night Live. I was so nervous. I was really green and I hadn't done much in front of a camera. I was scared and I wanted to do a good job because I loved the show so
会很棒。对，所以你认识他。你跟他是朋友。是的，我们是好哥们。所以我昨天给他打电话，他简直是世界上最忙的人。我说，罗布，你在哪儿？你在洛杉矶吗？因为我上次跟他说话时，他在苏格兰。哦，他正在做一些非常有趣的事情。但我跟他聊了聊，我说，罗布，关于杰克船长和整集“酒水游轮”，你还记得什么？他是这么说的。好吧。他说，嗯，安吉，从个人角度来讲，这是我离开《周六夜现场》后接到的第一批工作之一。我当时紧张极了。我真的很稚嫩，而且没在镜头前演过多少东西。我很害怕，我想把工作做好，因为我太喜欢这部剧
much and the character was so much fun. He also said he really enjoyed that we shot on the water and that it was a night shoot. And he said, you know, Ang, I don't know if you remember this, but no one could retreat to their trailers. Between scenes, you had nowhere to go. So we all hung out in that boat all night. We sat in the booths and hung out and people would sort of booth hop between scenes. You would have people that were like, oh, let's go talk to John and Jenna and Amy Adams and David Denman. Oh, let's go talk to the counting. Yeah. And so he said it was so fun. We would booth hop and everyone would hang out. And I really felt like I got to know some people that night. The second thing he
了，而且这个角色太有趣了。他还说，他真的很享受我们在水上拍摄并且这是一场夜戏的经历。他说，你知道，安吉，我不知道你还记不记得，当时没有人能退回到各自的房车里。场景之间，你无处可去。所以我们整晚都聚在那艘船上。我们坐在卡座里闲聊，大家会在不同的场景拍摄间隙在各个卡座之间串门。你会看到有些人说，哦，去跟约翰、詹娜、艾米·亚当斯还有大卫·丹曼聊聊吧。哦，去跟会计组聊聊吧。对。所以他说这太有趣了。我们会串卡座，大家聚在一起。我觉得那天晚上我真的结识了一些人。第二件他
said was he felt really bad for Steve because Steve was shooting Evan Almighty all throughout the day. And then he would come over to our set and film throughout the night. But even though Steve was so tired, he was still kind and thoughtful and professional. And he said that Steve really became an inspiration for him, for work ethic. Now, if you know Rob, you know he has an amazing work ethic, but he really saw that in Steve. Okay. So the third thing he said, and he was like, Ange, this is going to haunt me. It's haunted me for 14 years. What? He said, I had to say Lake Wall and Pawpack. And he said, Ange, did you just hear how I said that? Lake Wall and Pawpack. I said it like it just rolled
说的事是，他真的很替史蒂夫感到难过，因为史蒂夫一整天都在拍摄《冒牌天神2》。然后他还要赶到我们的片场拍摄一整夜。但尽管史蒂夫那么累，他依然很友善、体贴且专业。他说史蒂夫在职业道德方面真的成为了他的灵感源泉。如果你了解罗布，你就知道他有着惊人的职业道德，但他确实在史蒂夫身上看到了这一点。好吧。所以第三件事他说，他当时说，安吉，这件事会纠缠我。它已经纠缠我14年了。什么？他说，我必须说出“瓦伦帕普克湖”这个词。他说，安吉，你刚才听到我是怎么说的了吗？瓦伦帕普克湖。我说得就像它顺理成章地
off my tongue. Like I grew up there. Yeah. He said, I could not get it. He said, I don't even know if they had a usable take. He said, I must have messed it up 10 times in a row. He said, I started sweating. I was so embarrassed. He said, I could not say Wall and Pawpack. And he said, when his, when his like shoot was done and he was driving home, all he did on his drive home from Long Beach, it was like a, you know, an hour and a half drive as he was like Lake Wall and Pawpack. Wall and Pawpack. Wall and Pawpack. He said, I could say it with no problem in my car driving home. He said, but I could not say it in the take. And he said, and it's haunted me for 14 years. Rob, I love you. I know. And you guys, be
从我舌头底下滑出来一样。就像我在那儿长的一样。对。他说，我就是说不好。他说，我甚至不知道他们有没有哪个镜头能用。他说，我肯定连续说错了10次。他说，我都开始冒汗了，太尴尬了。他说，我就是说不出“瓦伦帕普克湖”。他说，当他的戏份拍完、开车回家时，他从长滩开回家的路上一直在做的就是——那是大约一个半小时的车程——他一直在念叨“瓦伦帕普克湖。瓦伦帕普克湖。瓦伦帕普克湖。”他说，他在车里开车回家时说得一点问题都没有。他说，但我在镜头前就是说不出来。他说，这件事纠缠了我14年。罗布，我爱你。我知道。还有，各位，
sure to check out Rob Riggle's new show on the Discovery Channel. It's starting March 8th. It's called Global Investigator. And he wanted me to let you guys know that it's going to air after naked and afraid. I said, well, Rob, that's a lead in. Rob is fantastic and I adore him. Thanks so much, Rob. Oh, that was amazing. Good intel, Ange. So we have yet another guest star on this episode, Brenda Withers plays Brenda, the corporate liaison sent on the booze cruise to keep tabs on Michael. And there's some fun facts about Brenda. Let's hear them. Brenda and Mindy Kaling were a writing team before the office. They wrote and performed in an off-Broadway play called Matt and Ben, which was about the friendship
千万别错过罗布·里格尔在探索频道的新节目。它将于3月8日开播。节目名叫《全球调查员》。他还想让我告诉大家，这节目将在《原始生活21天》之后播出。我说，好吧，罗布，这倒是个好档期衔接。罗布太棒了，我非常喜欢他。非常感谢你，罗布。哦，太棒了。好情报，安吉。我们在这一集里还有另一位客串明星，布伦达·威瑟斯饰演布伦达，她是公司派来“酒水游轮”监视迈克尔的联络员。关于布伦达有一些有趣的冷知识。我们来听听。布伦达和曼迪·卡灵在《办公室》之前是一个编剧团队。她们创作并出演了一部名为《马特与本》的外百老汇戏剧，内容是关于马特·达蒙和本·阿弗莱克的友谊
of Matt Damon and Ben Affleck. And they played Matt and Ben. Yes. Brenda played Matt and Mindy played Ben. It was set in 1995 and it tells the story of Matt and Ben before they were stars in their apartment fantasizing about being famous. It was a huge hit. It was a smash critical hit. I would have loved to see that. I looked up the New York Times review and it was just glowing. And this really put them on the map. And it's definitely what got Mindy noticed. We haven't even talked about this. We haven't even mentioned who's coming on the show today. I know. I was just about to let it roll off my tongue as if we had announced it. I know. I thought about it too. And I was like, wait, we didn't even
，她们在剧中分别饰演马特和本。是的。布伦达饰演马特，曼迪饰演本。故事设定在1995年，讲述了马特和本在成名之前在公寓里幻想自己成名的故事。这部剧大获成功。是一部轰动一时的评论界热门之作。我很想看看那部戏。我查了《纽约时报》的评论，简直是赞不绝口。这确实让她们名声大噪。这也绝对是让曼迪受到关注的原因。我们甚至还没聊到这个。我们甚至都没提到今天谁要来节目。我知道。我正准备顺嘴说出来，就好像我们已经宣布过了一样。我知道。我也想到了。然后我想，等等，我们甚至都还没
say. You guys, we have an amazingly huge, awesome, the guest of all guests is on today. Greg Daniels, the creator of the show is coming on the episode today. He's going to be here any minute. He is going to sit with us. We're a little giddy, as you can tell. We're super giddy. And I believe he went and saw this show and that's how he discovered Mindy. Yeah, we'll have to ask him. We'll ask him because he'll be here. Because he's going to be here. Yes, that's right. Greg Daniels, showrunner of the office and writer of this episode will be joining us. That's hilarious. Why did we not lead with that? Talk about burying Malide.
说。各位，我们今天迎来了超级巨大、棒极了、嘉宾中的嘉宾。节目的创作者格雷格·丹尼尔斯今天将来到这一集。他随时都会到这里来。他将和我们坐在一起。正如你所见，我们有点晕乎乎的。我们超级兴奋。而且我猜他去看过这场演出，这就是他发现曼迪的方式。对，我们得问问他。我们会问他的，因为他会来。因为他要来。是的，没错。《办公室》的剧集统筹兼本集编剧格雷格·丹尼尔斯将加入我们。这太搞笑了。我们怎么没有把这个作为开场白呢？这简直是把好料埋在后面了。
I think we're just so excited. I know I'm watching the clock because he's going to be here soon. So I was like, oh, let's get Fast Facts done because then Greg's going to be here. Oh, just get Fast Facts done. Hey now. Hurry up and get your Fast Facts done. I had a good tippin' for you, Fast Facts. No, I'm kidding. I'm kidding. All right. Well, let's finish with these Fast Facts so that Greg can get in here. Fast
我想我们太兴奋了。我知道我在看表，因为他很快就要到了。所以我当时想，哦，赶紧把趣味冷知识说完吧，因为格雷格马上就要来了。哦，赶紧把趣味冷知识搞定吧。嘿。快点把你的趣味冷知识说完。我有个好建议给你，关于趣味冷知识的。不，开玩笑的。开玩笑的。好吧，那我们赶紧把这些趣味冷知识讲完，好让格雷格能进来。趣味
Facts number three. We shot on location, guys, on a boat. On a boat. On a boat. This was outside of the Long Beach Harbor, which is about 45 minutes south of Los Angeles. We shot there for three days. Now for two of the days we filmed while the boat was docked. And then there was one night when we were moving. Because we were in Long Beach and they put us up at a hotel, I had these grand fantasies that we were going to be all hanging out back at the hotel and like kind of partying or something. I don't know. I like have this idea. I never really been on location before.
冷知识第三条。我们在外景地拍摄，伙计们，在一艘船上。在一艘船上。在一艘船上。这艘船在长滩港外，距离洛杉矶南部大约45分钟车程。我们在那里拍了三天。其中有两天我们在船停泊时拍摄。然后有一天晚上我们在航行。因为我们在长滩，他们给我们安排了一家酒店，我当时脑海里有很多宏大的幻想，以为我们都会在酒店大堂闲晃，然后大概会开个派对什么的。我不知道。我有这种想法。我以前从来没有真正拍过外景。
We never even saw the hotel. Literally, we were on the boat all night and we would go to the hotel and maybe sleep a few hours and then we'd go right back. I have no memory of the hotel. Of the hotel. No. But I did bring poker chips thinking that we would hang out at the hotel and play poker, but it never happened. We actually filmed from like late afternoon overnight until the sun came up. Yes. I wrote in my journal that we filmed from 2.30 p.m. and usually wrapped around
我们甚至都没怎么见识过酒店。字面意义上，我们整晚都在船上，然后去酒店睡上几个小时，接着马上又回去了。我对酒店没有任何记忆。对酒店没有。没有。但我确实带了筹码，以为我们会在酒店闲晃打扑克，但那从来没有发生过。我们实际上是从傍晚一直拍到通宵，直到太阳升起。是的。我在日记里写道，我们从下午2点半开始拍摄，通常在早上5点左右收工
5 a.m. and I wrote, I felt the motion of that boat all week the next week. I would be in line at the grocery store and realize I was swaying. Oh my gosh. It was intense because even when the boat wasn't moving, you're still on water. Well, yeah, even I actually think it's worse when you're just docked because then it's like doing this weird like a little, like a little, little, little, little, little kind of thing. And when you're moving, you know, it's better. It's like a forward motion, but that kind of
，我写道，接下来的一整周里，我一直能感觉到那艘船在晃动。我在杂货店排队时，会突然意识到自己在摇晃。我的天哪。这太强烈了，因为即使船没有开，你依然在水面上。好吧，是的，实际上我觉得停泊的时候更糟糕，因为那样它就会做那种奇怪的、一点点、一点点、一点点、一点点的小动作。而当船在航行时，你知道，情况会好一些。那是一种向前的运动，但那种
Totally. Rocking against the dock for days on it. Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh. Let's bring you back memories. I have some fantastic photos from this episode because I brought my camera, my old school camera. I already mentioned we got a photo when I found out I was serious regular, but I had it on the boat with me the whole time. So I have, I have so many. I was looking at all my office photos, all my memorabilia and booze cruise is a huge chunk of photos. I brought my camcorder back then. We didn't have iPhones on this boat, but I had a little
完全是。连续几天靠在码头上摇晃。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。这勾起了你们的回忆。我有一些来自这一集的精彩照片，因为我带了相机，我那部老式相机。我刚才提过了，当我发现自己成为常驻演员时我们拍了张照片，但我全程都把它带在船上。所以我有很多、有很多。我翻看所有《办公室》的照片、我所有的纪念品，“酒水游轮”占据了很大一部分照片。我当年带了摄像机。我们这艘船上可没有iPhone，但我有一个小型
camcorder and I filmed all of us behind the scenes. I remember this. A documentary of booze cruise, which you can find on YouTube. It is. It's on YouTube and like Jenna Fisher, booze cruise documentary. It'll pop up. It's amazing. I interviewed crew members. I asked them what they did. And it's very funny because you see us getting on the boat. Dave Rogers, our editor, I gave him all the footage and he put together this video.
摄像机，我把我们所有的幕后花絮都拍了下来。我还记得这个。一个关于“酒水游轮”的纪录片，你可以在YouTube上找到它。是的。它在YouTube上，搜“詹娜·费舍尔酒水游轮纪录片”就能弹出来。太棒了。我采访了剧组人员。我问他们是做什么的。这非常有趣，因为你能看到我们登船的过程。我们的剪辑师戴夫·罗杰斯，我把所有的素材都交给了他，他把这段视频剪辑在了一起。
You see us all getting on the boat. We're like, yeah, booze cruise. And then the first night we're like, yeah, booze cruise. We're still, we're doing it. We're doing it. Like by the third night, no one will speak to me. But you definitely see the progression. I watched the whole thing and it just made me smile. I just, man, it just brought me right back. And we also look 12 years old. We do. We just look so, I was like, oh man, time has marched on across my face.
你能看到我们所有人都上了船。我们当时就像，耶，酒水游轮。然后第一天晚上我们就像，耶，酒水游轮。我们还在拍，我们还在拍。到了第三天晚上，根本没人愿意跟我说话了。但你确实能看到这种演变过程。我把整段视频都看了一遍，它让我忍不住微笑。天哪，它一下子把我带回了过去。而且我们当时看起来只有12岁。确实。我们看起来太——我当时想，噢天哪，岁月已经在我的脸上留下了痕迹。
Oh no. I was like, wow, we look so young. Well that's all I've got. Should we go get Greg and bring him in here and break down this episode? Yes. Cause I have a ton of note cards. You really do. Angela guys got here early because she had so many notes that she was like, I came in and I was shocked. I said, what is this? Here it is though. All right. Well, let's do it.
哦不。我当时想，哇，我们看起来太年轻了。好吧，我掌握的就这些。我们要不要去把格雷格叫进来，让他加入我们并剖析这一集？好啊。因为我有一大堆卡片。你真的有很多。安吉拉今天来得很早，因为她准备了太多的笔记，我进来的时候都惊呆了。我说，这是什么？不过这就是全部了。好吧，那就开始吧。
Okay guys, we're back from our break and we are sitting here with Greg Daniels, writer of booze cruise, show runner of the office. Greg, thank you so much for coming in. Well, thank you so much for inviting me. I love your show. You guys are so good together. It's so entertaining to hear you and it's so fun for me to hear your voices and your points of view and everything. Thank you so much. If not for you, Greg, we would not be best friends and this show wouldn't exist. Our lives would be completely, I don't even know, I can't even put it into words honestly
好了，各位，我们休息归来，现在和我们坐在一起的是“酒水游轮”的编剧、《办公室》的剧集统筹格雷格·丹尼尔斯。格雷格，非常感谢你能来。哦，非常感谢你们邀请我。我太喜欢你们的节目了。你们俩在一起太棒了。听你们聊天非常有趣，听到你们的声音、观点以及一切对我来说也是一种莫大的乐趣。非常感谢你。格雷格，如果没有你，我们就不会成为最好的朋友，这个节目也不会存在。我们的人生将会彻底——老实说，我都无法用言语来表达
because now I'll get emotional. Here I go. Angela's crying already. I'm already, I can't, sorry. I just all kind of hit me. You know how Jim says he'll bet a paycheck that Michael in this episode is going to do the Titanic thing? Yeah. I would have said Angela was going to tear up, but I. And it happened already.
因为现在我会情绪激动。我要开始了。安吉拉已经在哭了。我已经，我不能，对不起。我只是各种情绪涌上心头。你知道吉姆怎么说他愿意赌上一个月的薪水，说迈克尔在这集里会做泰坦尼克号的动作吗？是的。我本来会说安吉拉会哭的，但是我已经。而且已经发生了。
It happened so soon. I know, I'm sorry. I just, it just all like the wave hit me of just gratitude I have for you, just absolute gratitude in my heart. Likewise. Yeah, you. It was a great time for all of us and if your friendship was the only thing that came out of it, that would be cool. Oh.
发生得太快了。我知道，我很抱歉。我只是，所有的感激之情如潮水般向我涌来，我对你的感激，我内心深处的绝对感激。彼此彼此。是的，你。对我们所有人来说都是一段美好的时光，如果你们的友谊是唯一收获的东西，那也很酷。哦。
And yet it's not. Is it? I know. Well, Greg, when we have guests, we always like to start with asking them, how did they end up being on the office? How did you end up developing the office for American television? I will go back a little ways because I was kind of already with a career at the time that the show started. You had a very successful career, Greg. I mean, you had done King, I won't list your
然而并不是。对吧？我知道。那么，格里格，当我们有嘉宾时，我们总是喜欢先问他们，他们是怎么最终加入办公室的？你最终是怎么为美国电视开发办公室的？我要稍微回溯一下，因为当节目开始时，我的职业生涯已经有了一定基础。你曾经有过非常成功的职业生涯，格里格。我的意思是，你做过《山丘之王》，我不会列举你的
IMDB, but you were the real deal. Go ahead. Well, you. I don't know it enough. You created King of the Hill. King of the Hill. And you were running that show. Yeah, yeah.
IMDB，但你是个真正的大人物。请继续。嗯，你。我不太了解。你创作了《山丘之王》。《山丘之王》。而且你当时在运作那个节目。是的，是的。
But you had written on Saturday Night Live and. Simpsons. The Simpsons forever. And oh my gosh, there's that one song that you wrote on the Simpsons that is just amazing. Anyway, okay, okay. Who needs a quickie mart? Yes, who needs? Yes.
但你曾在《周六夜现场》和。辛普森一家。永远的《辛普森一家》。噢天哪，你在《辛普森一家》里写的那首歌真是太棒了。不管怎样，好吧，好吧。谁需要快买便利店？是的，谁需要？是的。
Yes. Okay. So you were the real deal. It was, it was things were cooking. So yeah. So I was in a good position. You know how they say like, you need 10,000 hours to be good at something? Yes.
好的。所以你是真正的行家。当时，事情正在顺利进行。所以，是的。所以我处于一个很好的位置。你知道他们怎么说吗，比如，你需要一万小时才能精通某事？是的。
So I had sort of 10,000 hours on the Simpsons and Saturday Night Live. And then I had another like 15,000 hours on King of the Hill. So I was like prepared. And what happened was my agent sent me the tape of the office and it was pretty unknown over here. And it had a pretty boring title and I didn't watch it. The BBC version. The BBC version, yes.
所以我大概在《辛普森一家》和《周六夜现场》花了一万小时。然后我在《山丘之王》又花了大约一万五千小时。所以我准备好了。发生的事情是，我的经纪人寄给我一盘《办公室》的录像带，它在这里还挺不知名的。而且它有一个相当无聊的名字，我当时没看。BBC版本。BBC版本，是的。
And so he called me. It was over Christmas, like two years before our show came out. And he said, all right, I'm going to send this to somebody else if you don't watch it. And I was like, oh, okay, hang on, hang on, I'll watch it tonight. And I put it in around 11 and I stayed up till like three in the morning watching it. I thought it was just brilliant. So you know, I called and I said, I really want to meet these guys. And I had been kind of like a good little student, you know, always in my career.
所以他打电话给我。那是在圣诞节期间，大约在我们节目播出前两年。他说，好吧，如果你不看，我就把它寄给别人了。我就说，哦，好吧，等等，等等，我今晚看。我大概11点左右把它放进去，一直看到凌晨3点左右才看完。我觉得它简直太棒了。所以你知道，我打电话说，我真的很想见见这些人。我一直像个优秀的好学生，你知道的，在我的职业生涯中一直是这样。
And I always wanted to interact with people who I respected and, you know, I sold a episode to Seinfeld so I could work with Larry David and that was like a career important move for me. And I kind of identified that Ricky Gervais and Stephen Merchant had done something that put them in the top ranks of people working in this profession. So I really wanted to meet them. And I didn't really think it could be adapted. So I was kind of scamming them.
我总是想与我尊敬的人互动，你知道的，我向《宋飞传》卖了一集剧本，这样我就可以和拉里·戴维合作，这对我来说是职业生涯中非常重要的一步。我认出里奇·热维斯和斯蒂芬·莫昌特做了一些事情，让他们跻身这个行业中最顶尖的人才之列。所以我真的很想见他们。而且我真的不认为它可以被改编。所以我当时有点像在耍花招。
I was like, I'm going to go meet you and take this interesting meeting. Take your knowledge from you. Ask you questions. Build a relationship. Maybe for something in the future. You never know. What's not going to be this? And anyway, so we met over at Ben Silverman's office because he had the rights and we got
我想：我要去见你们，开个有趣的会。从你们那里获取知识。问你们问题。建立关系。也许为了将来的某种合作。你永远不知道。不会是这个吧？不管怎样，我们在本·西尔弗曼的办公室见面了，因为他拥有版权，我们相处得
along very well because it turned out that they loved American TV and specifically The Simpsons and specifically their favorite episode or Ricky's favorite episode was Homer Badman, which I had written. And so we kind of hit it off. Amazing. Yeah. And I was telling them, you know, all the kind of theories that I had about making a TV show that I put into place in King of the Hill, which was, you know, a slower pace and allowing
非常融洽，因为事实证明他们热爱美国电视，特别是《辛普森一家》，尤其是他们最喜欢的剧集或里奇最喜欢的一集是《讨厌鬼荷马》，那是我写的。所以我们一拍即合。太棒了。是的。我当时在告诉他们，你知道，关于制作电视节目的各种理论，这些理论我曾用在《山丘之王》中，也就是，你知道的，较慢的节奏，并留出
for awkwardness and realism and all this stuff and it was, they really responded to that. So we decided, well, maybe I would be the person to adapt it into America. And then there was a couple of, you know, months where we were kind of hammering it out and, but it was always the thought was always to bring it to someplace cool and cably because the show was not like what was on TV. You know, I think the biggest show at the time was Will and Grace, which was very kind of multi-camera, fast, far more broad. Yeah.
尴尬感和现实主义等等，他们对此深有共鸣。所以我们决定，也许我会成为把它改编到美国的人。然后有几个月的时间，我们一直在敲定细节，但总的想法始终是把它带到一个很酷的有线电视台，因为这个节目和电视上的其他节目不一样。你知道，我认为当时最大的节目是《威尔和格蕾丝》，那是非常多机位、节奏快、更加大众化的节目。是的。
Very different feel. You know, yeah. I didn't have a network feel of like television. Yeah. It felt weird. And so we were talking about, well, maybe we'll go to HBO and apparently Kevin Riley at FX really likes it. And so we had a couple of thoughts.
感觉非常不同。你知道，是的。它没有电视网节目的感觉。是的。感觉很奇怪。所以我们在讨论，也许我们会去HBO，显然FX的凯文·莱利非常喜欢它。所以我们有几种想法。
And anyway, so I signed on to do it. And then Kevin Riley left FX and went to NBC and HBO didn't want to do it because they didn't want to do a remake. And Ben was like, you got to sell this to NBC. And then I got very worried because I was like, this is not going to work on NBC, you know? You're like, this isn't what I signed up for. Yeah.
不管怎样，我签约做了这个。然后凯文·莱利离开FX去了NBC，HBO不想做，因为他们不想做翻版。本说，你必须把它卖给NBC。然后我变得非常担心，因为我想，这在NBC行不通，你知道吗？你会想：这不是我签约时说好的。是的。
Cool cable show. Yeah, exactly. And I also had these stress streams where I would be put on trial by all the comedy nerds in the world for doing this lousy NBC version of the office, you know? Yeah. Yeah. So, but eventually we were like, well, maybe, maybe the value of it will be to move network comedy into a new direction, maybe open it up just a little bit and make it more like
酷炫的有线电视节目。是的，完全正确。而且我还有过这样的噩梦般的幻想：我会因为制作了这个糟糕的NBC版《办公室》而被全世界所有的喜剧迷送上法庭审判，你知道吗？是的。是的。但是最终我们想，也许，它的价值在于将电视网喜剧带向一个新的方向，也许稍微打开一点，让它更像
what I liked about animation, which was single camera and didn't have a laugh track and stuff like that. So I was like, okay, I kind of convinced myself it was worth doing just for that. And it ushered in this whole new type of American television. Completely. All right. Well, let's get into booze cruise. All right.
我喜欢的动画片，也就是单机位拍摄，没有罐头笑声之类的。所以我当时想，好吧，我稍微说服了自己，仅仅为了这一点也值得去做。它开启了美国电视的全新类型。完全是这样。好吧，让我们进入“酒水游轮”吧。好的。
Let's do it, Jenna. What was the inspiration for this episode? You know, one of the things we were doing was we were looking for classic office situations and trying to test them for, was there comic potential? And the idea of going on a booze cruise sounded funny. And this was like our biggest episode yet. You know, this was where we were kind of feeling some oats as a show. And if you remember, they bought a whole bunch of hotel rooms for everybody.
我们开始吧，珍娜。这集的灵感是什么？你知道，我们当时在做的一件事是寻找经典的办公室情境，并测试它们是否具有喜剧潜力。去参加酒水游轮的想法听起来很有趣。这就像是我们迄今为止最大的一集。你知道，在这里，作为一部剧，我们开始展现出一些雄心壮志。如果你还记得的话，他们为每个人买了一大堆酒店房间。
And this was sort of going to be like the new thing. We were maybe going to have more location shooting and it was very exciting. Speaking of the booze cruise, when we were on the boat, I remember I was standing next to you and I had told you that I had been on a booze cruise and I had done a snorkel shot like when we were talking about that. Did we roll with that right away from that? No, no, no. We were, so I think we read, we had the table read, we read the script and I went up to
这有点像是新事物。我们可能会进行更多实地外景拍摄，这非常令人兴奋。说到酒水游轮，当我们在船上时，我记得我站在你旁边，我曾对你提起过我曾参加过酒水游轮，而且我做过潜水呼吸管喝酒法（snorkel shot），就像我们当时谈论的那样。我们马上就采用这个桥段了吗？不，不，不。我们当时，所以我想我们读过，我们有剧本围读，我们读了剧本，我走到
you and I was like, this is great. I said, you know, I went on one of these. And it is, it gets crazy. I mean, there were snorkel shots and you're like snorkel shots and you're like, okay, I want to talk to you more about snorkel shots. And then you kind of went off and we were like, just like, you were busy with the episode. It was a very big episode. And then we were on the boat and I think you had mentioned it to Phil Shea.
你面前说，这太棒了。我说，你知道，我参加过其中一个。而且它，确实很疯狂。我的意思是，有潜水呼吸管喝酒法，而你说潜水呼吸管喝酒法，你说，好吧，我想跟你多聊聊潜水呼吸管喝酒法。然后你大概就走开了，我们就像是，就像是，你正忙着这一集的事情。这是一个非常大的集。然后我们在船上，我想你向菲尔·谢伊提到了这件事。
And so he had snorkels. And I just remember all of a sudden I was like talking to Brian and Oscar and I heard, Angela, Angela, get over here. And it was you. And you're like, get over here. Talk to them about snorkel shots. I was like, oh, okay, you pour it at the top, but you know, and so we sort of had this quick snorkel shot tutorial and then it made it in the episode.
所以他准备了呼吸管。我只记得突然之间我正在和布莱恩还有奥斯卡说话，我听到，安吉拉，安吉拉，过来这里。那是你。你说，过来这里。跟他们聊聊潜水呼吸管喝酒法。我当时想，哦，好吧，你从上面倒进去，你知道的，所以我们大概进行了这个快速的潜水呼吸管喝酒法教程，然后它就被收录进这一集里了。
That's great. I forgot about that. It was just so fun. I always, we talk about this a lot, how you were so open to like, in the moment, like collaboration and getting people's ideas and it made for such a fun, awesome work environment. Yes, completely. I love the work that you guys did because, you know, part of the thing that I wanted to do with the show was like the experiences that I'd had that I didn't like in show business
太棒了。我都忘了这事了。真的太有趣了。我总是，我们经常讨论这一点，你对于即兴创作、团队合作以及采纳大家的意见是多么地开放，这造就了一个如此有趣、棒极了的工作环境。是的，完全如此。我喜欢你们做的工作，因为，你知道，我做这个节目的初衷之一就是，我在演艺界经历过但我不喜欢的事情
were mostly like factory made TV where they keep the writers over here and the actors are over here and nobody talks to each other and they got to get the scripts out fast and it didn't feel very creative. And I really wanted to mix it all and have a more handmade feel to it. And so I had, you know, I had a lot of the writers act and I would ask the some of the actors to write and I always love to get access to the kind of actor prepares work that you guys did and, you know, and I would hop on any great ad lib like that whole thing with Rain being Amish just came out of an ad lib, if you remember, where he was talking about
大多是像工厂制造的电视剧，他们把编剧留在这一边，把演员留在另一边，谁也不跟谁说话，他们必须快点弄出剧本，这感觉一点也不具创造性。我真的很想把它们融合在一起，有一种更多手工制作的感觉。所以我有，你知道的，我让很多编剧参与演戏，我也要求一些演员参与写作，而且我总是喜欢了解你们所做的“演员准备工作”式的演技，你知道的，我会采用任何精彩的即兴发挥，比如雷恩扮演阿米什人的整段内容就来自于一次即兴发挥，如果你还记得的话，当时他在谈论
his grandfather's name and he said Dwight Shrewd Amish and then we were like, ooh. And then you just ran with it. Yeah, that sounded fun. I also remember in the casting process, like I, you know, we, we initially wanted Steve and then he took that other show come to Papa before Alison Jones came on board. I don't know if you know that. No. Yeah.
他祖父的名字，他说德怀特·施鲁特是阿米什人，然后我们就想，哦。然后你就顺着演下去了。是的，听起来很有趣。我也记得在选角过程中，比如我，你知道的，我们最初想要史蒂夫，但在艾莉森·琼斯加入之前，他接了另一部剧《来吧，帕帕》。我不知道你知不知道这个。不知道。是的。
So we had heard, Ben had specifically heard about how great Steve was in Bruce Almighty and he really had that amazing sort of scene stealing moment where he's speaking in tongues as the newscaster. Yes. And everybody knew he was, you know, really great and would be a good choice for this. And I'm very methodical, as you know, and I was like, okay, that sounds great. First I want to get the casting director on board and I, you know, really wanted to use Alison Jones from her works on Freaks and Geeks, which I loved, and it took two weeks
所以我们听说，本特别听说史蒂夫在《冒牌天神》里的表现有多棒，他确实有那种令人惊叹的、抢尽风头的时刻，就是他作为新闻主播说方言的那段。是的。每个人都知道他，你知道的，真的很棒，会是这个角色的好选择。而且我很循规蹈矩，如你所知，我想，好吧，听起来不错。首先我想让选角导演加入，而且我，你知道的，真的想让艾莉森·琼斯加入，因为她之前参与制作过我非常喜欢的《怪胎与书呆》，这花了两个星期
to get her on board. And in those two weeks, Steve took this other show and you know, it might have been, yeah, it was awful. So then we went on this incredibly long process of looking at every single person in town who could possibly be in the age range for Michael Scott and including various writer friends that I had who I threw into the mix and, you know, just normal people like I'd be walking down the street and go, oh, you look good, you know, come in and read this. Yeah.
才把她请来。就在那两个星期里，史蒂夫接了另一部剧，你知道的，那可能，是的，太糟糕了。所以我们随后经历了一个极其漫长的过程，寻找城里每一个年龄段可能适合迈克尔·斯科特的人，包括我认识的各种编剧朋友，我都把他们拉进来参与甄选，你知道的，还有普通人，比如我在街上走着，会想：哦，你看起来不错，你知道的，进来读一下剧本。是的。
But anyway, it came full circle. And then after three months of intense casting, we got a little tip off from Kevin Riley that may become to Papa wasn't going to go the distance. And we could get Steve in second position to that other show and we'd be safe. And so. Let's get into booze cruise. Oh my gosh. All right.
不过无论如何，这事总算圆满了。在进行了三个月紧张的选角后，我们从凯文·莱利那里得到了一个内部消息：帕帕可能撑不了多久。我们可以让史蒂夫排在那部剧的第二顺位，这样我们就稳妥了。所以。我们来聊聊“酒船派对”。哦，天哪。好吧。
Talk to you all day. I have a cold open. I'm saying no card. No card. Oh, wait. He has a no card. No card. Minute 45.
跟你聊一整天都行。我有个开场白。我说没卡片。没卡片。哦，等等。他有没卡片。没卡片。第45秒。
Oh. Yes. Yes. An early one. I believe Kevin is packing a Speedo. A metallic blue Speedo. Yes. And lots of condoms.
哦。是的。是的。挺早的。我打赌凯文带了一条速比涛泳裤。一条金属蓝的速比涛泳裤。是的。还有大量的避孕套。
And condoms. Yes. And lots of condoms. He's also, we have a great Jim Pam talking head, a joint talking head, which I know was really fun for you guys to do right before that. Yes. Where we're reading the memo from Michael that he has sent around telling us to prepare for a surprise outing.
还有避孕套。是的。还有大量的避孕套。他还，我们有一个很棒的吉姆和帕姆的对齐访谈，我知道你们俩在那之前做这个觉得非常有趣。是的。我们在读迈克尔发来的备忘录，他发了一圈，告诉我们要为一次惊喜的外出做好准备。
He tells us to pack a toothbrush, a swimsuit, a ski mask, and wear your rubber sold shoes. I love how delighted Pam is by Jim and this talking head. And also at one minute, 53 seconds, please notice the winter Scranton backdrop outside of the window of our talking head. We would change those backdrops seasonally. They were, we had a springtime one, we had a summer and a winter. So this was our winter backdrop out the window. It was January on Lake Wallin Poppack.
他让我们带上牙刷、泳衣、滑雪面罩，还要穿上橡胶底鞋。我太喜欢帕姆听到吉姆说这些以及这个访谈时的喜悦表情了。另外在1分53秒时，请注意我们访谈窗外斯克兰顿的冬日背景。我们是按季节更换这些背景的。我们有春季的，有夏天的，还有冬天的。所以这是我们窗外的冬日背景。那是1月在沃伦帕帕克湖。
That's right. Stanley's like a booze cruise in January. And also on that note, like we said, we are jumping ahead, but at six minutes, 45 seconds, when Kevin is walking down the ramp to get on the boat, he is wearing a ski mask. There you see a man in a ski mask. Oh, Jenna, you're right. He followed the memo to a tee. Wait, okay, wait.
没错。斯坦利就像在一月份去游船派对。还有顺便说一句，就像我们说的，我们虽然跳跃了一点，但在6分45秒时，当凯文走下舷梯准备上船时，他戴着一个滑雪面罩。你在那儿看到了一个戴滑雪面罩的人。哦，珍娜，你说得对。他严格照着备忘录做了。等等，好吧，等等。
Now, wait, we do have to give our background people who love the background stuff in the cold open. What all is in the vending machine? Oh, yes. Oh, yes. The cold open. Jim puts Dwight's stuff in the vending machine. Pam buys Dwight's pencil cup, which is letter H is the pencil, pencil cup.
现在，等等，我们必须向那些喜欢冷场笑话里背景细节的背景迷们交代一下。自动售货机里都有什么？哦，是的。哦，是的。冷场。吉姆把德怀特的物品放进了自动售货机。帕姆买了德怀特的铅笔筒，字母H就是铅笔筒。
Someone did a deep dive. G is Dwight's desk nameplate. FF is a picture frame of Reign's actual family. Yes. Fan question. Hannah Watkins asked, there is a framed picture in the vending machine. Is that a real photo from Reign's childhood? It is a photo of Reign's aunt and uncle and nephew.
有人做了深入挖掘。G是德怀特桌上的名牌。FF是雷恩真实家人的相框。是的。粉丝提问。汉娜·沃特金斯问，自动售货机里有一个带框的照片。那是雷恩童年的真实照片吗？那是雷恩的姑妈、叔叔和侄子的照片。
Yes. Reign had brought in, I remember, a family photo album of sort of country cousins of his that lived in Oregon, I think, and that was part of what he was drawing from for Dwight. For his character. Yes. I think we put it in a frame. Yes. Oh, that's perfect.
是的。我记得雷恩拿来了一本家庭相册，里面好像是他在俄勒冈州住的乡下表亲，我想，这就是他塑造德怀特时取材的一部分。为了他的角色。是的。我想我们把它装进了一个相框里。是的。哦，那太完美了。
That's so good. HH was a stapler. I was Mike, Greg, I might say this wrong, Mike Lieberthal. It was a bobblehead of a Philly's baseball coach. I don't know. Yes. Well, that's something that you shouldn't really go to me for. I'll tell you that right now.
太棒了。HH是一个订书机。我是迈克，格雷格，我可能说错名字了，迈克·利伯thal。那是费城人队棒球教练的摇头娃娃。我不知道。是的。好吧，这事你可别来问我。我现在就告诉你。
There was, I mean, Phil Shea, who was a brilliant prop master on our show for the whole time of the show, used to go to Scranton and return with truckloads of chachkies from the different businesses and giveaway pens. I love that. Michael, sports figure, bobbleheads and stuff, and I think that was on the penguins, maybe. No, he was a Philly's. He's a Philly's? I looked him up.
那个，我是说，菲尔·谢伊，他是我们剧组自始至终才华横溢的道具师，过去常常去斯克兰顿，带回一卡车来自不同企业的廉价小商品和促销笔。我太喜欢这个了。迈克尔的体育人物摇头娃娃之类的，我想那是关于企鹅队的，也许吧。不，他是费城人队的。他是费城人队的？我查过他。
I Googled him. Mike Lieberthal, he was a Philadelphia Philly's catcher on their baseball team. And then also letter J is Dwight's wallet. Yes. And Jim gives Dwight a bag of nickels to get all his stuff back, which I love that detail. So then we go to the scene where Stanley goes into Michael's office to find out if they will be spending the night.
我谷歌了他。迈克·利伯thal，他是费城费城人队棒球队的捕手。然后字母J是德怀特的钱包。是的。吉姆给了德怀特一袋硬币让他把所有东西都买回来，我特别喜欢这个细节。然后我们转到这样一个场景：斯坦利走进迈克尔的办公室，想打听他们是不是要过夜。
And Michael is so coy and just loves that nobody knows where they're going. And Stanley says, should my wife tell her boss she's not coming in tomorrow? And he's like Stanley, both family, banana and a family, me, my, my, manly Stanley. Like he can't. No. Of course, Stanley can't get anything out because Michael's interrupting him with this ridiculous song. So that was also like an early season, uh, running joke was him changing people's names.
迈克尔装得神秘兮兮的，就是喜欢别人不知道他们要去哪儿。斯坦利说，我老婆该不该告诉她老板明天不去上班了？迈克尔就说，斯坦利，无论是家庭、香蕉还是家庭，我，我，我，男子汉斯坦利。就像他不能。不。当然，斯坦利什么也说不出来，因为迈克尔一直在用这首荒谬的歌打断他。所以这也是早期剧集里的一个小长青笑话，就是他老改别人的名字。
He did. He did it to Pam constantly. Oh yeah. Oh yeah. It's like we kind of dropped that after a few years. Oh yeah. He didn't. He didn't really do that to people anymore.
他确实这么干了。他总是对帕姆这么干。哦，是的。哦，是的。感觉我们过了几年之后就不用这个梗了。哦，是的。他没有。他真的不再对其他人这样了。
All right. So we move into the conference room where Michael finally reveals to everyone that they're going on a booze cruise of Lake Wall and Pawpack. I became obsessed with the question personally, do they really have booze cruises of Lake Wall and Pawpack? Yes and no. I did a deep dive on the internet. Okay.
好吧。于是我们来到会议室，迈克尔终于向大家透露，他们要去沃伦帕帕克湖参加一场游船派对。我个人对这个问题着迷了：沃伦帕帕克湖真的有游船派对吗？有也不是。我在网上深入研究了一下。
Um, so what they mostly have are pontoon boat tours, uh, open-air tours where a guide tells you about the scenery. Well that boat, the real boat that we filmed on was a boat from Long Beach Harbor and was big metal boat. I can't picture how it would have gotten to Lake Wall and Pawpack, which is, you know, it doesn't have. Yes. Also, I, I did a little bit of a deep dive.
嗯，所以他们主要有的是双体船观光，露天观光，由导游向你介绍风景。至于那艘船，我们拍摄时用的那艘真船是长滩港的一艘船，是一艘大型金属船。我想象不出它怎么能运到沃伦帕帕克湖去，你知道的，那个湖没有。是的。另外，我也稍微做了一点深入研究。
I think they have like a motor restriction law on Lake Wall and Pawpack. Yeah. So like you can only have, like, I don't think our boat size would be permitted. Well, supposedly they do have a dinner cruise, so if you're in the area, you can look that up. I'm sure there's beer and wine. I mean, I'm not sure, but. Wait, can we, okay.
我想沃伦帕帕克湖对马达有限制法律。是的。所以你只能，我觉得我们那种船的尺寸是不被允许的。好吧，据说他们确实有晚餐游船，所以如果你在附近，你可以查查看。我相信有啤酒和葡萄酒。我的意思是，我不确定，但是。等等，我们能，好吧。
In the conference room scene, first of all, these are some of my favorite scenes because Michael has something he's so desperately is trying to say and then we just keep interrupting him. He looked at the first draft of the episode and there is a scene that was in the first draft where Brenda, the person from corporate, tells Michael that she hears he's planning this booze cruise and she tells him that corporate won't pay for it unless it has a certain amount of educational content and he panics because he hadn't prepared anything. And then we go into the conference room scene and he's trying to make up stuff off stoppers
在会议室的场景里，首先，这些是我最喜欢的场景之一，因为迈克尔有些话拼命地想说，然后我们就不停地打断他。他看了剧本的第一稿，第一稿里有一个场景，公司派来的布伦达告诉迈克尔，她听说他在策划这个游船派对，并告诉他公司不会为此买单，除非里面包含一定量的教育内容，然后他开始恐慌，因为他什么都没准备。然后我们进入会议室场景，他开始瞎编。
head. Leader. Ship. It's all about the pause, but we had a very hard time keeping a straight face in the scene as we often did in conference room scenes and I caught a few people breaking and Mindy at three minutes 41 seconds when she says I took the tags off already when she's talking about her bathing suit because, you know, Michael says bring a bathing suit and now she doesn't need one.
头。领。导。全靠停顿，但在拍摄这个场景时，我们很难忍住不笑，就像我们在会议室场景中经常做的那样，我抓拍到了几个人笑场，曼迪在3分41秒时，当她说她已经把标签撕掉了，因为她在谈论她的泳衣，因为，你知道的，迈克尔说带件泳衣，现在她不需要了。
Mindy puts her hand to her mouth. Yeah. She covers her mouth. And that's what she would do when she was about to throw. That's her tail. Yeah. That's for sure. So easy.
曼迪把手放在嘴边。是的。她捂住了嘴。那是她快要吐的时候会做的动作。那是她的暗示。是的。绝对是的。太容易看出来了。
Her hair is half up, half down. Half up, half down. Kelly. We're tracking when Kelly is fully Mindy. Yes. Because, Greg, maybe you can shine some light on this. Mindy, the character of Kelly Kapoor started out as a very kind of like stuffy, up-do. Her hair was in a bun.
她的头发半扎半散。半扎半散。凯利。我们在追踪凯利完全变成曼迪的时期。是的。因为，格雷格，也许你能给我们解释一下。曼迪，凯利·卡普尔这个角色一开始是一种非常古板、盘着头发的形象。她的头发梳成一个发髻。
She always had like a paisley top on with like an ascot kind of thingy. And then she very slowly just turns into Mindy Kaling. Yes. Basically. And now she's, her hair has transitioned. This is a long campaign that Mindy waged behind the scenes taking, you know, and I know she plotted it and every, every step was a victory. And a lot of it would be, we'd kind of do a double take and go, hey, wait, what, what
她总是穿着一件佩斯利花纹的上衣，还戴着那种领结似的东西。然后她非常缓慢地就变成了曼迪·卡灵。是的。基本上就是这样。现在她，她的头发已经变了。这是曼迪在幕后发起的一场持久战，你知道的，我知道她精心策划了每一步，每一步都是胜利。而且很多时候，我们会大跌眼镜地说，嘿，等等，什么，你
are you wearing? And she would have, she would have slipped something in. Yeah. And she kind of hijacked that character and made it into her character. Well, we are enjoying watching the slow evolution of this has been really fun. Yes. I think her hair has now transformed, we're waiting for her wardrobe to transform. And also we're waiting for the first Beyonce reference, which has not happened yet.
穿的是什么？而她会悄悄换上一件衣服。对。她有点“绑架”了这个角色，把它变成了她自己的角色。好吧，我们很享受看着这个缓慢的演变过程，真的很有趣。是的。我想她的头发现在已经变了，我们在等待她的衣橱发生转变。而且我们还在等待第一个碧昂丝的梗，这个梗到现在还没出现。
Well, Brenda also, I don't know, this is maybe, was this a fast fact? Oh. Fast fact? I did discuss Brenda in Fast Facts, but we were going to come to you and ask you for your input about Brenda. Well, Brenda was Mindy's writing and performance partner in the play that is how I cast Mindy, because Mindy wrote this off-roadway play called Matt and Ben, about Matt Damon and Ben Affleck writing Goodwill Hunting.
好吧，布伦达也，我不知道，这也许，这是不是一个快速冷知识？哦。快速冷知识？我在快速冷知识里讨论过布伦达，但我们本来打算找你，问问你对布伦达的看法。好吧，布伦达是曼迪在话剧里的写作和表演搭档，我就是通过那部话剧选中曼迪的，因为曼迪写了一部名为《马特与本》的外百老汇话剧，讲的是马特·达蒙和本·阿弗莱克写《心灵捕手》的故事。
And Mindy played Ben Affleck and her, and Brenda, who's in Blue Screws, played Matt Damon. And it was a hilarious play. You went and saw it? Yes, I went and saw it. By accident or on purpose? No, I was actually, I was a guest of my wife, Suzanne Daniels, who was a network executive possibly at the WB at that time, I'm not exactly sure where she was working. And she went to see it to do talent scouting.
曼迪饰演本·阿弗莱克，而她和在《酒船派对》里演出的布伦达饰演马特·达蒙。那是一部非常搞笑的话剧。你去看过吗？是的，我去看了。是偶然还是故意的？不，其实我是和我妻子苏珊·丹尼尔斯一起去的，她当时可能是一位电视网高管，可能在WB工作，我不太确定她当时在哪里工作。她去看是为了物色人才。
And I thought it was super funny, yeah. And it was great. And then by coincidence, Mindy's spec script came in like the next day for me to read for staffing for writers. And I was like, hey, wait, that's the one I just saw on. Amazing. Yeah. Amazing.
我觉得超级搞笑，是的。而且非常棒。然后巧合的是，第二天曼迪的规格剧本就送到了我这里，供我评估是否录用编剧。当时我就想，嘿，等等，这不就是我刚看过的那部吗。太神奇了。是的。太神奇了。
Terrific. Wow. I would have loved to seen that. So, so now we have Brenda, and she's like the corporate person. You guys, I just have to point out something about Brenda. I know we're not on the boat yet, but Brenda drinks the whole boat ride. She's there to check in on Michael. She has a beer in her hand.
太棒了。哇。我真希望能看到那场演出。所以，现在我们有了布伦达，她是公司的代表。各位，我不得不指出关于布伦达的一点。我知道我们还没上船，但在整个航行过程中布伦达一直在喝酒。她是来监督迈克尔的。她手里拿着一杯啤酒。
You look, look at her scenes on the boat. She has a beer the whole time. She's at the bar. I mean, he only sees her when she's at the bar pretty much. Yeah. Or she walks up with a beer like to check in on him. Wait, before we get out of the conference room scene, Phyllis broke so hard. Do you remember this?
你看，看她在船上的那些场景。她从头到尾都在喝啤酒。她在酒吧里。我的意思是，几乎只有当她在酒吧时他才能看见她。是的。或者她拿着啤酒走过来监督他。等等，在我们离开会议室场景之前，菲莉丝笑得太厉害了。你还记得这个吗？
Oh, yes. Oh my gosh. Yes. So Michael has said that the sales team could be, is like the furnace of the ship. Yes. And it keeps, keeps things moving along. Yes. And it compares them to the people from Titanic.
哦，是的。哦，天哪。是的。所以迈克尔说销售团队可以，就像是船上的熔炉。是的。它让，让事情不断推进。是的。并把他们比作泰坦尼克号上的人。
Right. Titanic. And at five minutes, 20 seconds, Phyllis has to put her head down because she starts laughing because she says, she asks what the furnace does. And then at five minutes, 50 seconds, she says, everyone in the engine room drown. Do you remember that? Yes. She could not get out the word drown.
对。泰坦尼克号。在5分20秒时，菲莉丝不得不把头低下去，因为她笑得停不下来，因为她说，她问熔炉是做什么用的。然后在5分50秒时，她说，机舱里的人都淹死了。你还记得吗？是的。她就是说不出“淹死”这个词。
Like she couldn't. She just broke every time. And you can see her like starting to break. That would, that made me break on the day. Yes. Me too. When Phyllis was so sadly realized that everyone in the engine room drowned. From Michael, everyone drowned.
就像她做不到一样。她每次都笑场。你能看出她开始笑场了。那，那让我在现场也笑场了。是的。我也是。当菲莉丝如此悲伤地意识到机舱里的所有人都淹死的时候。来自迈克尔的，所有人都淹死了。
Well, now let's, we have to have the moment everyone gets on the boat. We've left the conference room. Yes. We're jumping around a little. At six minutes, 20 seconds, Michael says that Pam is Mary Ann, Katie and Jim are the professor and ginger, Angela's Mrs. Howell, Kelly's the native, Stanley is one of the globetrotters, Michael is a skipper and Dwight is Gilligan. And this begins the war between Captain Jack and Captain Michael.
好吧，现在，我们必须迎来每个人上船的时刻。我们离开了会议室。是的。我们跳来跳去的。在6分20秒时，迈克尔说帕姆是玛丽·安，凯蒂和吉姆是教授和金姬，安吉拉是霍尔太太，凯利是本地人，斯坦利是环球旅行者之一，迈克尔是船长，而德怀特是吉利根。这就拉开了杰克船长和迈克尔船长之间的战争。
Yes. I think that Michael has worn his Captain hat to the boost cruise. Yeah. He has it on in the boost cruise and he still has it on. And now they're having their little power struggle. Who is going to be the boss of this trip? Captain Jack is clearly going to win. I mean, I feel like his boundary is very strong from the beginning.
是的。我觉得迈克尔戴着他的船长帽来参加游船派对了。对。他在游船派对上戴着它，现在还戴着。然后他们开始争夺权力。谁才是这次旅行的老板？杰克船长显然会赢。我的意思是，我觉得他从一开始就划定了很强的界限。
Very strong. And I want you to know. We should say Captain Jack played by Rob Riggle. Yes. Who was a Marine. Yes. Who was a Marine. Yes.
非常强。而且我想让你知道。我们应该说杰克船长由罗布·里戈尔饰演。是的。他曾是一名海军陆战队员。是的。他曾是一名海军陆战队员。是的。
Yes. Who was a Marine. Military bearing there. Yes. How did you find Rob? Well, I mean, you know Rob, right? I know Rob. We talked a little bit about it in one of our fast facts, but Rob wanted me to give you
是的。他曾是一名海军陆战队员。身上有军人的风范。是的。你是怎么找到罗布的？嗯，我是说，你认识罗布，对吧？我认识罗布。我们在其中一个快速冷知识里聊过一点，但罗布让我带给你
a message. Yeah. Because I talked to him yesterday and he said, thank you so much. Also he's sorry that he couldn't say like while I'm popping. Rob was, you know, in the Allison Jones orbit. Yeah. So, and we certainly knew about him and I don't know whether he came in for one of the other parts like he might have come in for Dwight or something.
一个口信。是的。因为我昨天跟他聊过，他说非常感谢。另外他也为自己没法说出“沃伦帕帕克”感到抱歉。罗布你知道的，在艾莉森·琼斯的圈子里。是的。所以，我们当然知道他，我不知道他是来试镜其他角色的，比如他可能来试镜过德怀特什么的。
I'm not a hundred percent sure. Did that happen sometimes? People who had come in for main cast members, you would ping them for a future episode? Sure. Yeah. I mean, I think Allison released some of the audition tapes as part of the DVD Extra, but there were a lot of cool people that came in. It would have been very interesting to see Seth Rogen as Dwight, for instance.
我不是百分之百确定。这种情况有时会发生吗？那些来试镜主要演员的人，你们会把他们记在心里留作未来的剧集使用？当然。是的。我的意思是，我觉得艾莉森作为DVD花絮发布了一些试镜带，但确实有很多很酷的人来过。比如，看塞斯·罗根演德怀特会非常有趣。
Yes. Definitely. Or Kristen Wiig as Pam. Yeah. I think she came in to read Pam. Yeah. I think she's in my site on my, on my Allison Jones. Allison Jones.
是的。绝对的。或者克里斯汀·韦格演帕姆。是的。我想她来试读过帕姆的台词。是的。我想她在我的艾莉森·琼斯名单上。艾莉森·琼斯。
Yeah. Allison Jones gave me my sign-in sheet day and Katherine Hahn is on it and Bob Odenkirk is on it. Yeah. Well, Bob was really the number two. If we didn't have Steve, it would have been Bob. He did a great job. And then in season nine, we brought him back as the sort of echo.
是的。艾莉森·琼斯给了我当天的签到表，凯瑟琳·哈恩在上面，鲍勃·奥登科克也在上面。是的。好吧，鲍勃真的是第二人选。如果我们没有史蒂夫，那就是鲍勃了。他做得非常棒。然后在第九季，我们把他请了回来，作为一种呼应。
He was so fantastic too. Yeah. Yeah. He's great. So, I have a lot of fan questions about the boat. Sure. Okay. So, since we're getting on the boat, Casey Wright asked, was the boat right?
他也太棒了。是的。是的。他太棒了。所以，我有很多关于这艘船的粉丝提问。当然。好吧。既然我们要上船了，凯西·赖特问，这艘船真的是
The boat really moving and Sam Pellet asked how cold it was. The boat was really moving through the water for one of the days of shooting. The other two days, I believe it was docked and it was cold. It was December 2005, which was chilly, especially at night out on the water. A lot of people wondered, were you pretending to be that cold? I remember being cold. I don't think so. Yes.
在开吗？萨姆·佩莱特问当时有多冷。拍摄的其中几天，船确实在水面上航行。另外两天，我相信它是停靠着的，而且天气很冷。那是2005年12月，天气很凉，特别是晚上在水面上。很多人好奇，你们是在假装那么冷吗？我记得当时真的很冷。我不觉得是假装的。是的。
I don't think there was a lot of pretending. Your cheeks are like white pink in that scene. Yes. So, Lorne Michaels has a thing that he says sometimes where, like, he will get in-character underwear for the actors and, yeah, I think this is it. And people will say, well, why? Who cares? It's not going to be on camera.
我觉得不需要怎么假装。在那个场景里，你们的脸颊白里透红。是的。所以，洛恩·迈克尔斯有一个习惯，他有时会为演员准备符合角色设定的内衣，是的，我想就是这样。人们会问，为什么？谁在乎呢？镜头又拍不到。
And he goes, yes, but the actors know. I kind of get that. I kind of get that. And so, we certainly believed in that and went out on this real boat in Long Beach Harbor and it was this huge thing. And to me, the key of it was that romantic scene on the top deck between Pam and Jim. And I just thought it'd be so pretty up there with the twinkling lights of the harbor and the background and everything.
而他说，是的，但演员自己知道。我有点理解。我有点理解。所以，我们当然坚信这一点，开着这艘长滩港的真船出海，那是个大工程。对我和我而言，其中的关键是帕姆和吉姆在顶层甲板上的那场浪漫戏。我只是觉得在那上面配上港口闪烁的灯光、背景和一切，会非常漂亮。
So we do that scene and later in the editing room, somebody was like, what did you do? Did you just put a row of Christmas lights against a black piece of duvetine there and do it in a studio? And we're like, no. We're on a boat. We're on an actual boat, but it didn't really look that impressive when it came down to it was just this one little twinkle thing of lights on the horizon. Like we could have been on a sound stage.
于是我们拍了那场戏，后来在剪辑室里，有人问，你们干了什么？你们是不是就在一块黑色的杜芬呢面料前挂了一排圣诞彩灯在摄影棚里拍的？我们说，没有。我们在船上。我们在一条真正的船上，但拍出来看起来其实没那么震撼，地平线上只有那么一点一闪一闪的灯光。就像我们本可以在一个消音舞台里拍一样。
Yeah, we could have been nice and toasty and comfortable. But the wind was blowing and I don't know. I could tell you're on a boat. I think so. Yeah. Well, one of the challenges of being on the boat was how sick everyone got. Great. Do you remember that?
是的，我们本可以舒舒服服、暖暖和和的。但当时风很大，我不知道。我能看出你们是在船上。我想是的。是的。好吧，在船上的一大挑战是大家晕船晕得有多厉害。格雷格。你还记得吗？
We were all really sick. Yeah, there was a lot of sickness. Great people were really throwing up. But I did not get seasick. But do you remember coming up to Kate Flannery and I and saying, hey, you guys, I want to get some b-roll of people vomiting off the side of the boat? Correct? I don't.
我们都病得很厉害。是的，很多人都在呕吐。格雷格，人们真的在呕吐。但没有晕船的我。不过你还记得你走到凯特·弗兰纳里和我面前说，嘿，伙计们，我想拍一些人们在船舷呕吐的B卷素材吗？对吗？我不记得了。
But that would be something I would have done. It was like three in the morning. And you said, so you had Matt so and grab as many people as he could. And we had the choice of cream of mushroom or menastrone. Oh, right, right, right. The fake vomiting. The fake vomiting. The fake vomiting.
但这确实是我会做的事。当时大概是凌晨三点。你说，你让马特去找尽可能多的人来。我们有蘑菇汤或意式蔬菜汤可以选择。哦，对，对，对。假装呕吐。假装呕吐。假装呕吐。
And I did. I did menastrone. Yeah, good choice. You had to take a swig of it and hold it in your mouth until action and then puke it. And the, I don't know, five to 10 seconds you held it in your mouth was horrible thing because you were just like, like trying not to gag. So I didn't puke for real, but I did fake puke. Well, I got really sick.
我照做了。我选了意式蔬菜汤。是的，好选择。你得喝上一大口，含在嘴里直到导演喊开始，然后吐出来。而且，我不知道，你含在嘴里那五到十秒钟太可怕了，因为你只是像，拼命忍住不作呕。所以我不是真吐，我是假吐。不过我真的病得很重。
So did David Denman. And I was wearing those wristbands. Yes. Did anybody pass out boning too or stuff? Yeah, there was all, there were all these remedies, but nothing really works. Seasickness gum. Someone gave me something to chew on. Maybe the gum.
大卫·丹曼也是。而且我当时戴着那种防晕手腕带。是的。有人晕得直吐或者怎么样吗？是的，有各种各样的，有各种偏方，但其实都没什么用。晕船口香糖。有人给了我一块嚼的东西。也许是口香糖。
Yeah. There's like a ginger gum. So at one point, the real captain of the boat heard that I was struggling. There were three captains. And then there was also, there was Dwight steering the ship and a guy and then a real guy. So at one point, the real captain of the ship heard I was struggling and he got out this oil that he rubbed behind my ears.
对。有一种姜味口香糖。所以有一次，船上的真船长听说我很难受。船上一共有三位船长。然后还有，当时有德怀特在掌舵，还有一个伙计，然后还有一个真船长。所以有一次，船上的真船长听说我很难受，他拿出了某种油，抹在我的耳朵后面。
And about 10 minutes later, I was totally fine. So I've written about this in my diary. I looked it up and I found some on Amazon. Here's what's in it. Here's where we turn this whole thing into an essential oils pitch podcast. By the way, we're sponsored by, sold by Jan, Jan's essential oils and candles. So here's what it has in it. Lavender, peppermint, chamomile, something called Ylang Ylang, birch, and then it has
大约10分钟后，我就完全没事了。所以我把这事写进日记里了。我查了一下，在亚马逊上找到了。里面有这些东西。这就是我们把整件事变成精油推销播客的地方。顺便说一句，我们由简、简的精油和蜡烛赞助、销售。所以里面有这些成分。薰衣草、薄荷、洋甘菊、一种叫依兰的植物、桦木，然后它还有
frankincense and myrrh. That's the stuff that the wise men gave to Jesus. Yeah. I know. Two of the things. Expensive. Very expensive stuff. Yeah.
乳香和没药。那是智者送给耶稣的东西。对。我知道。其中两样东西。很贵。非常昂贵的东西。对。
Fancy. Who knew? I didn't even, I mean, I know frankincense and myrrh are real, but I didn't know they were real. I mean, I thought they were part of a Christmas song. It's not real, but like, what are they? I guess they are what you rub behind your ears when you're seasick. It sounds like they just threw everything in the kitchen sink into this.
真高级。谁知道呢？我甚至，我是说，我知道乳香和没药是真实的，但我不知道它们是真正存在的。我是说，我以为它们只是圣诞歌的一部分。它不是真的，但是，它们是什么？我想它们就是你晕船时抹在耳朵后面的东西。听起来他们把厨房里能用的东西全扔进这里面了。
Yeah. The Ylang Ylang. I don't know. Ylang Ylang. Ylang Ylang. All right. So in the script, there was a scene, Greg, that as the boat is pulling away, Toby's car suddenly drives up and he, and Michael yells at him from the ship, oh, come on, what's
对。依兰。我不知道。依兰。依兰。好了。所以在剧本里，有一个场景，格雷格，当船开走时，托比的车突然开了过来，然后他，迈克尔在船上对大喊，哦，拜托，那是
that? He's like, I'm sorry, there was, there was an accident or there was traffic. And then Michael says, we're not going back. We're not going back from him. Just leave him. And then Paul turns to camera as Toby and he kind of gives a little wink. Yeah. It's a big smile.
什么？他好像在说，对不起，有，有事故，或者有交通堵塞。然后迈克尔说，我们不回去了。我们才不为他回去呢。随他去吧。然后保罗饰演的托比转向镜头，他露出了一个坏笑。对。这是一个灿烂的微笑。
Yeah. Like he did on purpose, but you can find that in the deleted scenes. We shot it. Yes. We shot it. And it was very nice. And that is why Toby is not on the boat for anyone who was wondering. Maybe we should take.
对。就像他是故意的一样，但你可以在删减片段里看到。我们拍了。是的。我们拍了。而且非常棒。这就是为什么托比没有上船的原因，对于任何好奇的人来说。也许我们应该拍。
There's a lot of excuses for why Toby wouldn't be on things so that he could help out as a writer and producer. Toby and BJ and Mindy, like they sat in the, you know, Mindy was in the Annex, like things like that. I thought I was so clever in season one, making them actors so that they would have this experience of being actors. And then at some point in season two, I'm looking around and 50% of the writers are gone. They're on set.
有很多借口解释为什么托比不参与某些事情，这样他就可以作为编剧和制片人去帮忙。托比、B.J.和敏迪，他们坐在，你知道的，敏迪在附属办公室里，诸如此类的事情。我在第一季觉得自己太聪明了，让他们当演员，这样他们就能体验到当演员的感觉。然后到了第二季的某个时候，我环顾四周，50%的编剧都不见了。他们在片场。
I'm like, oh, what have I done? Okay. At seven minutes, 55 seconds, Rob Riggle breaks. He totally breaks. What? We talked about it. We talked about it in the shot. So Rob is Captain Jack is going over the safety features of the boat.
我就想，哦，我都干了些什么？好的。在7分55秒时，罗布·里格尔笑场了。他彻底笑场了。什么？我们讨论过。我们在镜头里讨论过。所以罗布，杰克船长正在介绍船上的安全设施。
And Michael really wants to hijack this speech and give it. And he can't. So he just starts doing like the flight attendant, like pointing to the exits. And Rob just breaks. He just starts laughing, but he just keeps going. And then Rain is Dwight laughs. And so it just sort of like, but it stays in. Oh, that's amazing.
迈克尔真的很想抢过这个演讲来做。但他做不到。所以他开始像空乘人员一样，指着紧急出口。然后罗布就笑场了。他只是开始笑，但他一直在继续。然后雷恩饰演的迪怀特笑了。所以它就像那样，但它被保留下来了。哦，太棒了。
But Rob was like, yeah, I just, I just laughed and I, but I just kept talking through my laugh. And then Steve is doing his dancing that I remember like trying to build the reactions because everybody's supposed to be like unimpressed and just, you know, straight faced. And it was almost impossible because everybody was breaking and made him do that over and over and over again. For so long. Yeah.
但罗布当时说，是的，我只是，我只是笑了，我，但我只是笑着把台词说完了。然后史蒂夫在跳他的舞，我记得当时试图建立大家的反应，因为每个人都应该是那种无动于衷、表情严肃的样子。这几乎是不可能的，因为所有人都笑场了，导演让他一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍地做那个动作。持续了那么久。对。
I remember, I was, I remember when we rewatched it, I just wrote, oh my gosh, Michael's dance because he danced for so long. Yeah. In the journal, I said that we started taping that around 2am. Like it was really late. Yeah. A fan question from Tara Leitchke. Was Steve's dance choreographed?
我记得，我，我记得当我们重看这一段时，我只写了，哦天哪，迈克尔的舞蹈，因为他跳了太久了。对。我在日记里写过，我们大约在凌晨2点开始拍摄。时间真的非常晚。来自塔拉·莱奇克的粉丝提问。史蒂夫的舞蹈是编排好的吗？
I don't think so. I really think he improvised that. I don't remember it being in the script. I think he just kind of went for it. I have the script at home for this episode and I read it and there is no direction for Michael's dance in the script. It just says pan over to see Michael doing a weird dance. Yeah.
我不这么觉得。我真的认为那是他即兴发挥的。我不记得剧本里有这个。我觉得他当时就是豁出去了。我家里有这一集的剧本，我读过，剧本里对迈克尔的舞蹈没有任何指导。上面只写着镜头切过去，看到迈克尔在跳一段奇怪的舞。对。
That's it. That was as much as there was. Another fan question about the dance, Steve Dresser says, how many takes of that superb dance did it take to get Steve's full moves? I'm going to say about six, I think. Yeah. What do you think? What do you remember?
就是这样。剧本里就只有那么多。另一个关于舞蹈的粉丝提问，史蒂夫·德雷瑟问，为了拍出史蒂夫的全部舞姿，那段精彩的舞蹈拍了多少条？我要说大约六条吧，我觉得。对。你觉得呢？你还记得吗？
That seems about right. I can't remember when he started slapping his legs. Yeah, that was amazing. If that was early on or later. On the worm. I feel like there were different versions of the dance and then we kind of made the highlight reel. Yes.
这听起来差不多。我不记得他什么时候开始拍打自己的腿了。对，太惊艳了。那是挺早的时候还是后来。跳太空步的时候。我觉得那段舞蹈有不同的版本，然后我们挑选了精华片段。是的。
And on the deleted scenes, you can see even more of the dancing if you want to. I remember when Ken finally was like, okay, cut, Steve was on the ground doing the last one. He got up and everyone applauded for him and you guys came over and gave him a hug because he had really gone for it. I was exhausting. Yeah, he completely did. That was amazing.
在删减片段里，如果你想看的话，可以看到更多舞蹈。我记得当肯终于说，好吧，咔，史蒂夫正趴在地上跳最后一个动作。他站起来，所有人都为他鼓掌，你们走过去给了他一个拥抱，因为他真的是全力以赴了。我当时累极了。对，他完全做到了。太棒了。
That was a great question. Was their music playing when Michael danced or was it added later? My memory is that it was added later. I mean, I feel like what we often did was we would do one take with the music and then somebody would have a little earwig, you know, and they would say, do you want to do it with an earwig? And a lot of effort had gone into making a tiny invisible thing that could play the soundtrack and then the actor would go, no, I don't need it.
这是一个很好的问题。迈克尔跳舞的时候有音乐在放吗，还是后来加的？我的记忆是后来加的。我的意思是，我觉得我们经常做的是，我们会带音乐拍一条，然后某人戴着一个小耳塞，你知道的，他们会说，你想戴着耳塞跳吗？为了制作一个可以播放音轨的微小隐形设备，我们花了很多精力，然后演员会说，不，我不需要。
And then do the next five takes just for memory. That's how I feel like it probably went down. I do remember some fun facts about the band on booze cruise. Yes, we had a lot of questions about the band. Yes, exactly. Because my friend Bob Deal Jr., as you were pointing out on your card, who did our theme song was in the band and three out of the four band people were the guys who played our theme song, Hal Craig and Dylan also Dylan O'Brien, who's a big songwriter in LA.
然后仅凭记忆拍完接下来的五条。我觉得当时可能就是这样的。我确实记得关于“酒船派对”里乐队的一些有趣的事实。是的，我们有很多关于乐队的问题。是的，没错。因为我的朋友鲍勃·迪尔二世，正如你在卡片上指出的那样，他创作了我们的主题曲，他就在乐队里，乐队的四个人中有三个人就是演奏我们主题曲的人，哈尔、克雷格和迪伦，还有迪伦·奥布莱恩，他是洛杉矶的一位大词曲作者。
And these guys were friends of mine or Bob was and the theme song for the office was written by Jay Ferguson, but he sent over a version of it on synthesizer, which was, you know, a little, it was great. It was obviously a great song, loved it, but it was didn't sound, didn't have the energy that you'd want. And so Bob had this kind of rock and band that he put together of his friends and we went and recorded the theme song with all live instruments in a session. Yeah.
这些人是我的朋友，或者鲍勃是，办公室的主题曲是由杰·弗格森创作的，但他发过来一个合成器版本，你知道，有点，这很棒。这显然是一首好歌，很喜欢，但听起来，没有你想要的能量。所以鲍勃组建了这样一个由他的朋友们组成的摇滚乐队，我们在录音室里用全乐器现场录制了主题曲。对。
That is so cool. I did not know that. Yeah. That is so cool. And then he became, you know, then he called his band the Scrantones and then he came to Scranton with us and would play at our parties often. And he was, he was in the, I had a fan write in and say that he's also in Phyllis's wedding with Kevin in Scrantonicity.
太酷了。我当时并不知道。对。太酷了。然后他成了，你知道的，后来他把他的乐队命名为“斯克兰顿人”，然后他和我们一起去了斯克兰顿，经常在我们的派对上演奏。而且他，他在，我有一个粉丝写信说他也出现在菲yllis的婚礼上，和凯文一起在斯克兰托尼城乐队里。
I had a fan as well, Vanessa McLoad said that she noticed that at least one of the band members shows up later in Scrantonicity at Phyllis's wedding. Yeah. It's Bob. Oh. Bob, you know, Bob also did music, the music for Sons of Anarchy and the Mayans. So he's, he's quite talented. So talented.
我也有一个粉丝，瓦妮莎·麦克劳德说她注意到至少有一个乐队成员后来出现在菲yllis婚礼上的斯克兰托尼城乐队里。对。那是鲍勃。哦。鲍勃，你知道的，鲍勃还为《混乱之子》和《玛雅帮》做过音乐，音乐。所以他相当有才华。非常有才华。
I have at 11 minutes, 14 seconds. This is really crazy if you know these three people, Phyllis, Kevin and Angela are dancing together. Oh. What? I'm telling you. Is there a shot of, of Phyllis dancing with Creed at one point? Yes.
在11分14秒时。如果你认识这三个人，菲yllis、凯文和安吉拉在跳舞，这真的很疯狂。哦。什么？我跟你说。在某个时刻，有一个菲yllis和克里德跳舞的镜头吗？是的。
Yes. Towards the end there is, they're dancing together, but we're doing that, that awkward dance where like, I almost feel like, um, like an eighth grade where like a group of girls dance together except it's me, Phyllis and Kevin and we're just kind of doing like a little sway like that. It's just very funny to me. Well, I don't know if you remember Greg, but there was a runner, I read it in the script and then I went back and I saw it in the deleted scenes.
是的。到快结束时是有的，他们在一起跳舞，但我们在跳那种尴尬的舞，就像，我甚至觉得，嗯，就像八年级的时候，一群女孩聚在一起跳舞，除了那是我和菲yllis还有凯文，我们只是在做那种小幅度的摇摆。这对我来说非常搞笑。嗯，我不知道你是否还记得，格雷格，但有一个贯穿情节的副线，我在剧本里读到过，然后我回去在删减片段里看到了。
There was this whole runner through this episode that Oscar is a really mean drunk. Yes. So on the loose cruise. I'm glad we cut that. Yeah. I didn't like that. I read the script too and I was like, ooh. Glad we didn't use this.
这一集里有一条完整的副线，奥斯卡是个酒品很差的醉鬼。是的。就是在酒船派对上。很高兴我们把它剪掉了。对。我不喜欢那样。我也读了剧本，当时我就想，噢。很高兴我们没用这个。
Oh my gosh. And then he's just, he's getting drunk and then he's going around and he's insulting all of you. So that is probably why Oscar is not dancing with you guys. And also later. He's isolated himself. Yeah. Later it's just Kevin and I in the booth.
哦，天哪。然后他喝醉了，四处走动，侮辱你们所有人。所以这可能就是为什么奥斯卡没有和你们一起跳舞的原因。而且后来。他孤立了自己。对。后来只有我和凯文在卡座里。
Yeah. That's probably why. Because Oscar's off like talking about you. Oh, I forgot about that. Well, I want to go back to the scene with Jim, Katie, Pam and Roy sitting around the table. Great. So Katie makes a comment where she says, oh, we're at the cool table and then they all talk about what they were like in high school, except Jim.
对。可能就是这个原因。因为奥斯卡走开去说你们的坏话了。哦，我都忘了这事了。好吧，我想回到吉姆、凯蒂、帕姆和罗伊围坐在桌子旁的那个场景。好的。所以凯蒂发表了评论，她说，哦，我们坐在酷哥桌旁，然后他们都谈论了自己高中时的样子，除了吉姆。
We don't hear about Jim, but we find out that Katie was a cheerleader and that Pam was artsy fartsy. Thanks, Roy. And that Roy played sports and then Amy does her little cheer, Amy as Katie does her awesome cheer and that was not in the script. We found out on the set that Amy Adams was a cheerleader and she knew a bunch of cheers and she did, you had her do little cheers for us to react to. Amy and I did a few cheers together.
我们没听到关于吉姆的事，但我们发现凯蒂曾是个啦啦队长，而帕姆有点装腔作势。谢谢你，罗伊。还有罗伊做过运动，然后艾米跳了她的一小段啦啦队舞蹈，艾米饰演的凯蒂跳了一段精彩的啦啦队舞蹈，这不在剧本里。我们在片场发现艾米·亚当斯曾经是啦啦队长，她会跳很多啦啦队舞蹈，她跳了，你让她给我们跳了一小段啦啦队舞蹈来做出反应。我和艾米一起跳了几段啦啦队舞蹈。
We were all really punchy, you guys. It was like three in the morning, you know. So do you remember, because I remember when we were doing that scene and Amy started to do the cheerleader stuff. We did a couple of takes of it and then Ken wanted to move on and something was bothering me and I didn't want to move on from that scene. And I realized that the balance, she kind of shifted the balance because Amy Adams obviously very charismatic, you know, beautiful actress and she did that really fun, cute cheerleader
大家伙，我们当时都兴奋过度了。那是凌晨三点左右，你知道的。所以你还记得吗，因为我记得当我们拍那个场景时，艾米开始跳啦啦队的舞蹈。我们拍了好几条，然后肯想往下拍，有些事情困扰着我，我不想就这么跳过那个场景。我意识到这种平衡，她某种程度上打破了平衡，因为艾米·亚当斯显然非常有个人魅力，你知道，是个漂亮的演员，她做了那个非常有趣、可爱的啦啦队
thing. And then we were going to move on and I realized like Pam is just basically not participating on the same level here. She's kind of denying the cheerleader thing, but she isn't doing her own charismatic thing. And we went back and at 9 0 9, I went back to you and I said, you got to kick this up a notch, do something. Do you remember that? Yeah.
动作。然后我们就准备往下拍了，我意识到帕姆基本上没有在同一水平上参与。她有点否认啦啦队这件事，但她又没有展现出她自己迷人的一面。我们倒回去，在9分09秒，我走到你面前对你说，你得把这情绪提升一个档次，做点什么。你还记得吗？对。
And then you kind of mocked her cheerleader thing and you did that and I was like, yeah, because that was not in the script. That wasn't. That was added in the moment. And that's, yeah, I kind of flirt with Jim there. I know. I have a private moment at the table. I thought that was like so bold with Roy sitting next to you.
然后你有点模仿了她的啦啦队动作，你做了那个动作，当时我就想，太棒了，因为这不在剧本里。不在。那是当场加入的。然后，是的，我在那里跟吉姆调情。我知道。我在桌子旁有一个私密时刻。我觉得在罗伊坐在你旁边的情况下，这也太大胆了吧。
Like when I watched it again, I was like, wait, she's flirting with Jim with Roy next to her and also kind of making fun of Katie. Yeah. I was like, Pam's having a moment. Well, I think it was an important connection there, Greg, because it is certainly going to help give Jim the courage to do what he's going to attempt to do, which is tell Pam his feelings. I think without that little moment of them bonding over how ridiculous their significant
当我再次看的时候，我就想，等等，在罗伊在旁边的情况下她跟吉姆调情，而且还顺便取笑了凯蒂。对。当时我就想，帕姆正经历着美妙的时刻。嗯，我觉得这是一个重要的情感连接，格雷格，因为这肯定有助于给吉姆勇气去做他打算做的事，也就是向帕姆表白他的心意。我觉得如果没有那个小小的时刻，让他们因为他们的另一半有多荒谬而产生共鸣，你就不会把他们看作是那种心意相通的情侣。所以吉姆才不会觉得这可能会是我的时刻而显得那么突兀。
others are being, it's like you need to see them as that bonded couple. So it doesn't come so out of the blue that Jim would think this could be my moment. Well, also, Pam really gives them an opening on the top of the boat there. She does. Yeah. That to me, the Jim thing of it was she's engaged and he wants to be a good person and respect the fact that she's engaged, but he's also like, there's all these clues coming in that there could be something and he doesn't go for it and it's very frustrating to watch.
嗯，还有，帕姆在船头确实给他们留了个机会。她确实给了。是的。对我来说，吉姆的那部分在于她订婚了，而他想做一个好人，尊重她订婚的事实，但他也觉得，所有的线索都在涌现，表明他们之间可能会有些什么，而他却没有采取行动，这看起来非常令人沮丧。
It is. It's so painful to watch, but also feel so honest because that's how you would be. You wouldn't, you'd want to say everything and you wouldn't be able to. I remember, to me, that was probably one of the most personal and raw things that I would have put into a script because it did not feel like a very noble Jim successful social guy moment. It felt really like people are going to hate him for this or disrespect him or whatever. So I kind of felt it was risky to put it out there.
确实如此。看着太虐心了，但也让人觉得无比真实，因为这就是你的真实反应。你不会，你会想说出一切，但你却说不出口。我记得，对我和我来说，这可能是这可能是我写进剧本中最私密、最赤裸的时刻之一，因为它感觉一点也不像一个高尚的、春风得意的吉姆会做的事。它真的让人觉得人们会因此讨厌他、不尊重他或者别的什么。所以我觉得把它展现出来是有风险的。
I don't know, it was very hard also in the edit to keep it that long. I mean, we tried to make the same length that you guys really did in the scene and there was a lot of urge to trim that up. That's an awful long time to have people not talk. Yes. Let's talk about that. It's so beautiful. It's so beautiful.
我不知道，在剪辑中要保持这么长的时间也非常困难。我的意思是，我们试图做到和你们在现场表现的一样长，而且有很多冲动想要把它剪短。让人一言不发地呆那么长时间，实在是太久了。是的。我们来谈谈这个。太美了。太美了。
Pam and Jim are on the deck of that boat and Pam does give him an opening. She says, sometimes I just don't get Roy and this is the first time we've seen her complain about Roy to Jim, to disparage her relationship, really, it's the first time she's verbalized it. I don't, I'm pretty sure. And then it is 27 seconds of silence. And a fan wrote in, Anthony Snead said, what was the motivation behind that awkward silence? There's a lot going on in those 27 seconds, just because people aren't talking doesn't
帕姆和吉姆在那条船的甲板上，帕姆确实给了他一个机会。她说，有时候我就是搞不懂罗伊。这是我们第一次看到她向吉姆抱怨罗伊，贬低她的感情，真的，这是她第一次用言语表达出来。我不知道，我挺确定的。然后就是长达27秒的沉默。一个粉丝写信来，安东尼·斯尼德说，那段尴尬沉默背后的动机是什么？在这27秒里发生了很多事情，仅仅因为人们不说话并不
mean nothing's going on. And I think that you look at his face and you can see him trying out different things and thinking and being urged to go forward and blocked. And then I think also on your face, there's all this kind of like disappointment that he's not going to do anything and face saving when you're like, well, I'm cold and kind of, it was kind of good that it was cold, actually. And we really did shoot it out in the harbor because I think you wouldn't have been able to like your nose was red.
意味着什么都没发生。我想你看着他的脸，你能看到他在尝试不同的事情，在思考，在被催促着向前迈进却又受阻。然后我想在你的脸上，也有那种他什么都不做时的失望，还有当你说“嗯，我很冷”时的自我保护，其实，天气冷其实挺好的。我们确实是在海港里实景拍摄的，因为我觉得如果不那样的话，你的鼻子就不会红了。
Yeah. I was cold. Yeah, you were cold. Yeah, I believed it. Now, Greg, it wasn't in the script that there would be a big pause. It didn't say there's a long, big pause. Yeah. It just says that they look at each other and then finally Pam says, yeah, but I remember
对。我很冷。对，你很冷。对，我相信了。现在，格雷格，剧本里并没有说这里会有一个巨大的停顿。上面没有写有一个长长的、巨大的停顿。是的。上面只写着他们看着对方，然后最后帕姆说，是啊，但我记得
on the day you really encouraging us to take our time and don't be afraid to just look at each other. Well, I mean, that was part of, I think what made the show so special was that and so different from what was on TV, was that moments of behavior were really important more so than jokes and setups and punchlines and lines and stuff. And I think that came out of appreciating what's good about a documentary. And documentaries just are all about finding the truth in what people are doing and leaning in and no matter what they think they're doing or what they say they're doing, what are their
拍摄当天，你真的鼓励我们要放慢节奏，不要害怕只是看着对方。嗯，我的意思是，那是其中的一部分，我觉得这正是让这部剧如此特别、与电视上其他节目如此不同的原因，那就是行为的瞬间比笑话、铺垫、妙语和台词之类的事情更重要。而且我觉得这来自于对纪录片优点的欣赏。纪录片就是去发现人们行为中的真实，去深入挖掘，无论他们认为自己在做什么，或者他们说自己在做什么，他们的行动向你展示了他们在做什么。
actions show you that they're doing. And this was like a good romantic example of it all being in between the lines and it all being on the faces and not in the script. That is so smartly said. You guys, should we talk about what else was going on during this scene? Do you mean when half of the cast got lost at sea? Yes. All right, so here's the deal.
这就像是一个很好的浪漫例子，一切都在字里行间，一切都在脸上，而不在剧本里。说得太精辟了。各位，我们该聊聊这个场景拍摄时还发生了什么吗？你是说当一半的演员在海上迷路的时候吗？是的。好的，事情是这样的。
When we started this scene, I think we knew it was going to take a while. And so they told the other cast members that they could leave for the day, but the only way to get off the boat, because we weren't going to take the boat back and dock it. No, there were these little dinghies that would pull up and you would get in the little boat and it would take you to shore. Exactly. Well, that did not go as planned. No, it didn't.
当我们开始拍这个场景时，我想我们知道这会花很长时间。所以他们告诉其他演员可以离开去过夜了，但是离开船的唯一方法，因为我们不打算把船开回去停靠。不，有那些小橡皮艇会靠过来，你坐上小船，它会把你送到岸边。没错。嗯，事情并没有按计划进行。不，没有。
I remember getting this panicky radio thing. The boat with Phyllis on it is gone. Look, look, look at my card. You were on the boat too. I was stranded on the boat. Yeah. And Brian too, right? And Rain, and I wrote about it in my journal.
我记得接到了一个恐慌的对讲机通话。载着菲yllis的船不见了。看，看，看我的卡片。你也在船上。我也被困在船上了。对。还有布莱恩，对吧？还有雷恩，我在日记里写过。
Yeah. It was crazy. Well, for some reason, it fixated on me that it was Phyllis. The Phyllis was that we had lost Phyllis. She seems like the most vulnerable of the group, right kind Phyllis. Yeah. So, so I wrote her about and she. I can't wait to hear what she says.
对。太疯狂了。嗯，不知为什么，我满脑子都是菲yllis。我们弄丢了菲yllis。她看起来是这群人中最脆弱的一个，心地善良的菲yllis。对。所以，所以我写了关于她的事，她。
Yeah. Well, she says the first memory, she says it was about 2.30 in the morning and she was waiting to leave the ship and her first memory was seeing Steve Carell on a tiny little boat holding onto some kind of a pole with no lifejacket disappearing into the night and she remembers thinking that if NBC knew that their star was just didn't have a lifejacket and was, you know, being pulled off back to the harbor, they would be upset. And then she got on the boat and she thought it was Oscar, Brian, and somebody from the wardrobe department.
我迫不及待地想听她说什么了。嗯，她说最初的记忆，她说大约是凌晨2点半，她正等着离开这艘船，她最初的记忆是看到史蒂夫·卡瑞尔坐在一艘极小的船上，抓着某种杆子，没有穿救生艇，消失在夜色中，她记得当时想，如果NBC知道他们的明星没有穿救生艇，而且，你知道的，被拉回海港，他们会生气的。然后她上了船，她以为那是奥斯卡、布莱恩和服装部门的某个人。
I wrote about it the day. It was you. Yeah. No, she says, I'm not sure if Angela was there or not. And then she talks, everything was fine pulling away. We were enjoying the smell of the ocean, the lights and the distance. And then all of a sudden, nothing, the engine died. So you were there.
我当天就把这事写下来了。就是你。对。不，她说，我不确定安吉拉当时在不在。然后她谈到，开船时一切都很好。我们正在享受海洋的气味、远处的灯光。然后突然之间，什么都没有了，发动机熄火了。所以你在场。
So this is what I wrote the day after we filmed the scene. All right. I wrote, one of the coolest things that happened to me while we shot this episode happened in the last night, or I guess I should say the morning of rain, Phyllis and Brian and I were all wrapped at 5 30 a.m. We were on the main boat, but they said they had more shooting to do. So we could stay on the big boat and like sleep in a booth. Yeah.
所以这就是我拍完这个场景第二天写的内容。好的。我写道，拍摄这一集时发生在我身上最酷的事情之一发生在最后一晚，或者我想我应该说是清晨，雷恩、菲yllis、布莱恩和我在早上5点半都收工了。我们在大船上，但他们说还有镜头要拍。所以我们可以留在船上，像睡在一个卡座里。对。
Or they said they had these little rubber boats that would pull up next to the big boat that we could get on and they would take us to shore. So we said, okay, we'll do that. They said it's about a 15 minute boat ride on the little rubber dinghy. So we decided to do it. It was really tricky getting on the rubber boat. We just had to climb out of the ladder off the side of the boat and these guys. It was very unstable.
或者他们说有那些小橡皮艇会开到大船旁边，我们可以坐上去，它们会把我们送到岸边。所以我们说，好吧，我们就这么办。他们说坐小橡皮艇大约需要15分钟。所以我们决定这么做。上橡皮艇真的很难。我们不得不从大船侧面的梯子爬下来，然后这几个人。非常不稳定。
Phyllis said that at one point she had to switch boats. She was terrified of falling in. Yes. And I said, okay, the little rubber boat, picture the kind of like rubber boat that the Navy SEALs do the backflips off of with the little like me like outboat. That's what this looked like. So we're lowered down into it and it was me, Rain, Jen, one of our wardrobe gals, Phyllis and Brian.
菲yllis说她有一刻不得不换船。她吓得要掉进水里了。是的。我说，好吧，那艘小橡皮艇，想象一下那种海豹突击队在上面后空翻的橡皮艇，带着一个小型的舷外发动机。这就是它看起来的样子。所以我们被放下去，上面有我、雷恩、简、我们的一个服装姑娘、菲yllis和布莱恩。
It was tiny and really bouncy. We took off. It was dark out and the ocean looked like black glass. It was very peaceful. Oh, it's so quiet here. Sorry. About five minutes into our ride, our engine made a weird whirring sound and stopped working. And then we heard the boat driver radio and say, the engine's dead.
它很小而且弹跳得很厉害。我们出发了。天色已黑，大海看起来就像黑色的玻璃。非常平静。哦，这里太安静了。抱歉。大约开了五分钟后，我们的发动机发出奇怪的嗡嗡声，然后熄火了。接着我们听到船夫用对讲机说，发动机坏了。
You need to come get us. It started laughing and said, you've got to be kidding me. Then we just floated in the darkness, which felt like for a while it was quiet and peaceful. It turned into the Titanic. I know. I know. And then we live with another rubber boat pulled up and then we had to just straddle from one rubber boat with just two guys kind of holding it together into the other one.
你们得来接我们。开始大笑，然后说，你在逗我吧。然后我们就漂浮在黑暗中，感觉有一会儿时间既安静又和平。结果变成了《泰坦尼克号》。我知道。我知道。然后我们遇到了另一艘开过来的橡皮艇，接着我们不得不从一艘橡皮艇跨到另一艘上，只有两个家伙勉强扶着。
This was very tricky. We slowly made our way past the Queen Mary picture an old cruise ship that looks like the Titanic. And there was a huge plume of fire coming from a refinery behind it. Rain said to me, this is so surreal. And that's exactly what it was. You know, the wheels really came off when we went on locations. We talk about this a little bit.
这非常棘手。我们慢慢驶过玛丽女王号，想象一下一艘看起来像《泰坦尼克号》的老式游轮。后面的一家炼油厂腾起巨大的火苗。雷恩对我说，这太超现实了。事实也确实如此。你知道的，当我们去外景地时，情况真的失控了。我们稍微聊一下这个。
I mean, you know, this is for season nine, but you know, death bus almost killed us all. Yes. Work bus. Work bus. I should say. We've called it death bus for so long. The cast calls it death bus. All right.
我的意思是，你知道，这是为了第九季，但你知道，死亡巴士差点把我们都害死。是的。工作巴士。工作巴士。我应该这么说。我们把这车叫死亡巴士叫了太久了。演员们都管它叫死亡巴士。好的。
So we'll take a break and we'll be back. All right, so we're back from break. I have a question for you, Greg. Yeah. I've been waiting to ask you this. I know we're sort of jumping around with time codes, but at 11 minutes, 34 seconds, there's this beautiful shot that goes outside of the boat and goes around the boat. You passed white, right?
那我们休息一下，一会儿回来。好了，我们休息回来了。我有个问题问你，格雷格。是的。我一直等着问你这个。我知道我们在时间码上有点跳跃，但是在11分34秒，有一个非常漂亮的镜头，拍到了船的外侧，绕着船转了一圈。你白过了，对吧？
Like steering. And it goes around the boat. How did we do that? That is Kent Zabornak. So Kent was our line producer and he was also in the DGA and, you know, he managed to launch us on the budget that we had, which was tiny, you know, into Long Beach Harbor on a boat for days and get hotel rooms for everybody. And he realized that we really needed that a shot like that.
就像掌舵一样。它绕着船转。我们是怎么做到的？那是肯·扎博纳克。肯是我们的执行制片人，他也是DGA（美国导演工会）的成员，而且，你知道，他设法让我们在仅有的微薄预算下，在长滩港的一艘船上拍了好几天，还为每个人订了酒店房间。他意识到我们真的需要这样一个镜头。
And he shot that himself with his own equipment, you know, while we were shooting the rest of it, because he just had an instinct that there was no way the production could get that and stop everything. And, you know, so that was kind of a gorilla move and super valuable. And Kent was, you know, fantastic at doing those kind of things. Like he was always stitching together amazing stuff on our little budget. That is so cool. I did not know that.
他用自己的设备亲自拍了那个镜头，你知道的，在我们拍其他部分的时候，因为他有一种直觉，觉得制作团队绝不可能腾出时间去拍那个然后停下所有的工作。所以，那算是一个游击式的举动，超级有价值。肯，你知道的，非常擅长做这种事情。就像他总能在我们的小预算里把惊艳的素材拼凑在一起。太酷了。我当时并不知道。
But when I saw it, I was like, wait, I know Randall and Matt were inside with us. Yeah, who did that? Our camera guys. I was like, how did that happen? And then I was like, is that a plane? It's in the air. Like how that, I mean, it's in a drone. Like what is it?
但当我看到时，我就想，等等，我知道兰德尔和马特和我们在一起。是的，那是谁拍的？我们的摄像师。当时我就想，那是怎么做到的？然后我就想，那是飞机吗？它在空中。怎么会这样，我的意思是，那是无人机吗？到底是什么？
He's on one of those dinghies. He's on one of those zodiac dinghies. He's on a dinghie. Okay. Yeah. All right. Wow. This is another question about a camera movement.
他在其中一艘小艇上。他在其中一艘佐迪亚克橡皮艇上。他在小艇上。好的。是的。哇。这是另一个关于镜头运动的问题。
So, you know, after they're at the bar and they're all talking about who they would save, Jim gets up his courage and he's going to walk over to Pam and he says, I would save the receptionist. I think I need to make that clear. Well, right before that, Greg Phelps noticed at 14 minutes, 37 seconds, there's a continuous shot of Jim looking down the length of the boat to Pam. As he thinks about who he would save the camera then zooms in on Pam at the exact moment. She has a really cute laughing smile.
所以，你知道，在他们去酒吧之后，大家都在谈论他们会救谁，吉姆鼓起勇气，他要走向帕姆，他说，我会救前台。我想我得把这点说清楚。好吧，就在那之前，格雷格·菲尔普斯在14分37秒注意到，有一个连续镜头，吉姆顺着船长长的走廊看向帕姆。当他思考他会救谁时，镜头接着在精确的时刻拉近拍到帕姆。她露出了一个非常可爱的微笑。
How did you time that out so perfectly? He wants to know, Jenna, were you given a cue when the camera was about to zoom in on you? But we used to do that stuff all the time. Yeah. That was, go ahead. People, I think, have the wrong idea about how we did the show in a way because like most filmmaking is super intentional and you would say to the camera operator, okay, at
你是怎么把时间掐得这么准的？他想知道，珍娜，当镜头准备拉近拍你的时候，有人给你暗示吗？但我们以前经常做那种事。是的。那是，你接着说。人们，我想，对我们制作这部节目的方式有着错误的理解，因为大多数电影制作都是超级刻意的，你会对摄像师说，好的，在
this signal, you need to zoom in and then you'd try and get the actor to do it at exactly the right time. And our show was more like the theory of natural selection kind of like there would be a situation and I would give notes or the directors would give notes to the camera operators that were not about what they did specifically, but more about their intentions. So we would say, okay, we're really interested in what he sees down at the end of the hall. So just go find it. And we had all these people who had come from reality shows who were used to finding the
这个信号出现时，你需要拉近镜头，然后你会试图让演员在准确的时间做出反应。而我们的节目更像是自然选择理论，某种程度上，会有这样一种情况，我会给意见，或者导演会给摄影师意见，这些意见不是关于他们具体做什么，而是更多关于他们的意图。所以我们会说，好的，我们真的很想知道他在大厅尽头看到了什么。所以去把它找出来。我们有所有这些来自真人秀节目的人，他们习惯了自己去寻找
story on their own. And that turned out great, you know, and I can't really speak for Ken as the director, he directed it and he might have known exactly what he was going for and kept doing it until he got it. But a lot of the times they were just lots of happy accidents. And then you'd tell the story through all the happy accidents and you had enough like flexibility that you could have gone a bunch of different ways with it. I think our editors don't get enough credit.
故事。结果证明这很棒，你知道的，我不能代表肯作为导演的立场，他执导了这一集，他可能确切地知道他在追求什么，并一直拍下去直到拍到想要的。但很多时候，它们只是许多快乐的意外。然后你通过所有的快乐意外来讲述故事，并且你有足够的灵活性，可以用很多不同的方式来处理它。我觉得我们的剪辑师没有得到足够的赞赏。
Well, first of all, I think our our camera operators and yeah, don't get enough credit for all of those happy accidents. But then you would assemble those with the editors in the editing room to tell even more of a story than what was in the script. Really the editors are amazing. We had fantastic editors. This one was Dean Dave Rogers is, you know, I'm still working with work with them all the time.
好吧，首先，我觉得我们的摄像师和，是的，没有为所有这些快乐的意外得到足够的赞赏。但随后你会和剪辑师在剪辑室里把这些组合在一起，讲述比剧本里更多的故事。剪辑师真的很棒。我们有非常棒的剪辑师。这一集是迪恩·戴夫·罗杰斯，你知道的，我一直还在和他们合作。
Brilliant. Claire Scanlon also brilliant. And there was enormous amounts of leeway for the editors and in post because like a documentary, we shot way more stuff than we could ever possibly use. And so our rough cuts were always about 38 minutes long. But the show is only 21 minutes, you know, six seconds or something like that. So tons of good material was discarded. And that was like a large part of my job.
才华横溢。克莱尔·斯坎伦也才华横溢。后期制作中有巨大的余地，因为就像纪录片一样，我们拍摄的素材远多于我们可能用到的。所以我们的粗剪版总是大约有38分钟长。但剧集只有21分钟，你知道，6秒左右的样子。因此，大量的优质素材被丢弃了。这占了我工作很大一部分。
Like I I loved being on set, you know, and I also loved being with the writers, but this whole other area of my job was sitting with the editors and, you know, and they're fun people too with great, you know, creative ideas. And you could tell so many different versions of the show by what you left in and what you took out. And like there was and there was always a thing where you'd like, we go, everybody kind of agreed on the first six or eight minutes to get rid of, you know, and like it probably we all agreed like having Oscar make snarky, mean comments is not great or whatever it is.
就像我，我喜欢在片场，你知道的，我也喜欢和编剧们在一起，但我的另一大块工作是和剪辑师坐在一起，你知道的，他们也是有趣的人，有着极好的、富有创造力的想法。你可以通过留下什么和拿掉什么来讲述许多不同版本的节目。而且总是会有这样一种情况，你会觉得，我们大家在剪掉前六到八分钟这一点上达成了一致，你知道的，可能我们都同意让奥斯卡说那些尖酸刻薄的话并不是很好，不管是什么。
But then you'd get to like about 26 minutes and there was a lot of really good stuff. And I used to have all these regrets about things that were great that couldn't get in the show. And one of them for this, if you remember, was Creed sitting in with the band and us finding out that he'd been in the grassroots. And that was like fantastic. And we had all this footage and I found footage of him from, you know, late sixties and, you know, playing guitar with the grassroots on Playboy After Dark with Hugh Hefner and like
但接着你会看到大约26分钟的地方，那里有很多非常好的东西。我以前对那些很棒却无法放进剧本里的东西感到非常遗憾。其中之一，如果你还记得的话，就是克里德和乐队一起坐着，我们发现他曾经在草根乐队里呆过。那简直太棒了。我们有所有的这些素材，我找到了他在六十年代末的素材，你知道的，在休·海夫纳主持的《花花公子深夜秀》上和草根乐队一起弹吉他，就像
all these, all this great footage, which was going to be the B-roll under the, you know, under him talking about playing with all these greats in the late sixties and that was in for a really long time. I think it's in the DVD extras. It is. It's in the deleted scenes. It's great. It's great.
所有这些，所有这些伟大的素材，原本要作为B卷放在他谈论在六十年代末和所有这些伟大人物一起演奏的经历下面，那段素材保留了很长时间。我想它在DVD花絮里。确实在。在删减片段里。太棒了。太棒了。
The guitar player is going to take a break and then Michael tries to fill in for him and he's horrible. And then Creed says, let me give it a shot. And then he just gets that up there and rocks out and it's so cool and satisfying. And then he has a talking head where he explains that he is himself basically. He is Creed Breton, a member of grassroots. And that he kind of fried his brain with drug use and now he can barely concentrate on his job.
吉他手要休息一下，然后迈克尔试图替补上场，但他糟糕透顶。然后克里德说，让我来试试。接着他走上去摇滚起来，那真是太酷、太令人满足了。然后他有一个谈话头的镜头，在镜头前他解释说他基本上就是他自己。他是克里德·布拉顿，草根乐队的成员。他因为吸毒把脑子搞坏了，现在他几乎无法专心工作。
And then there's a talking head of Angela going, he wasn't that good or something like that. I've seen better. Oh man. By the way, I would wear a shirt that says I'd save the receptionist. I think that is. We should have shirts that say I'd save the receptionist. I think that's so cute.
然后还有一个安吉拉的谈话头镜头，说他没那么好，诸如此类的话。我见过更好的。哦天哪。顺便说一句，我会穿一件印有“我会救前台”字样的衬衫。我觉得那真是。我们应该做印有“我会救前台”字样的衬衫。我觉得那太可爱了。
I think Ken did a really good job with that too because that was, I believe, supposed to just be a talking head. And yes, in the script, it's a talking head and he really rightly said, well, where exactly did he say this? He, you know, he, he had the thought and then he walks over to Pam and then she gets interrupted by Roy setting a date. So he couldn't figure out where there was going to be a time to interview him about this.
我觉得肯在这方面也做得很好，因为那是，我相信，原本应该只是一个谈话头。是的，在剧本里，那是一个谈话头，他非常正确地指出，好吧，他到底是在哪里说的这话？他，你知道，他有了这个想法，然后他走向帕姆，然后她被罗伊宣布订婚日期打断了。所以他弄不清在哪里会有时间采访他关于这件事的想法。
And so he, it's sort of invented this on the fly interview where he kind of just passed the cameraman and set it into camera then and it was cool. Yeah. Very cool. I really liked that. No, and you're with him. Like Jim's got his courage. He's going to save the receptionist.
所以他，这有点像是临时拼凑的即兴采访，他当时只是路过摄像师，然后直接对着镜头说了出来，这很酷。是的。非常酷。我真的很喜欢那个。不，而且你和他在一起。就像吉姆鼓起了勇气。他要救前台。
He almost gets up to Pam and that's when Roy stands up and says that he's setting a wedding date, June 10th. A fan question from Ed's arquisa said, was Pam genuinely happy when Roy proposed or was she just caught up in the moment? Well, I looked at the script. The script said Pam looks happy. So I played it that Pam was genuinely kind of overcome with this moment. You know, she's been trying to get Roy's attention.
他几乎走到了帕姆身边，就在那时罗伊站起来说他在定结婚日期，6月10日。来自埃兹·阿尔奎萨的粉丝提问说，帕姆在罗伊求婚时是真的开心，还是只是被当时的氛围感染了？嗯，我看过剧本。剧本上写着帕姆看起来很高兴。所以我把帕姆演成是真的有点被这个时刻所压倒。你知道的，她一直试图引起罗伊的注意。
I think she wants him to treat her like this so badly. And so she's also invested years into this relationship and I feel like I feel for her cause she's like, all right, we're going to, we're going to do it. This is it. Yeah. I think it makes it so much worse too because he had his moment on the deck and she was quite receptive there and then he didn't go for anything. And then here, look how happy she is that she, you know, finally after three years of
我觉得她太希望罗伊这样对待她了。而且她也在这段感情里投入了多年，我觉得我能理解她，因为她想，好吧，我们要，我们要结婚了。就是这个。是的。我觉得这也让事情变得更糟，因为他在甲板上时有过他的时刻，而她当时非常接受，然后他什么也没做。然后在这里，看看她是多么高兴，你知道，在经历了三年的
being, you know, strung along and then, and then you could just picture like, oh, I, maybe I could have made that face on her if I'd said something upstairs, you know. Yes. Yeah. Yes. It's heartbreaking. And then he's mean to Katie. Well, Amy's, first of all, Amy's reaction is so sweet.
漫长等待之后，然后，然后你可以想象，哦，如果我在楼上说点什么的话，我是不是也能让她露出那样的表情呢。是的。是的。是的。太心碎了。然后他对凯蒂很粗鲁。嗯，艾米的，首先，艾米的反应太可爱了。
So sweet. She is, I mean, she's waiting for her moment. She, please propose to her somebody because she's like, oh my God. This is amazing. Yeah. Amazing. Okay. Jim breaks up with Katie very abruptly.
太可爱了。她，我是说，她在等待她的时刻。她，求求谁来向她求婚吧，因为她当时想，哦天哪。这太棒了。是的。太棒了。好的。吉姆非常突然地和凯蒂分手了。
Jibbity Jenkins actually wrote in, I said, Jibbity, Jibbity Jenkins, you, you, but you just, you just first, it's not real. Also, you just rolled into it. Like I thought it was part of your sentence you're like, and then Katie, Jibbity Jenkins. Yeah. I was like, is this like a, like a Missouri thing, Jibbity Jenkins from Dogpatch, Jibbity Jenkins. Jibbity Jenkins says, Jim was kind of a dick to Katie, the entire cruise for no reason
吉比·詹金斯实际上写信进来说，我说，吉比，吉比·詹金斯，你，你，但你刚刚，你刚刚首先，这不是真的。而且，你只是顺着说下去了。就像我以为那是你句子的一部分一样，你说，然后凯蒂，吉比·詹金斯。是的。当时我就想，这就像是一个，就像是密苏里州的某种梗，来自狗狗补丁的吉比·詹金斯，吉比·詹金斯。吉比·詹金斯说，吉姆在整个航程中对凯蒂都有点像个混蛋，没有别的理由
other than he wanted to be with Pam. She's really innocent through all this. And then he just breaks up with her. Also, don't break up with someone on a boat. Well, yeah. There was the, a lot of the writers said that too, to me, and I thought it was the most efficient breakup you could possibly have pretty much, you know, and we always had time issues and I just didn't really want to see a long drawn out scene with Katie and
只是因为他想和帕姆在一起。她经历了这一切却真的很无辜。然后他直接跟她分手了。还有，不要在船上跟人分手。嗯，是的。有很多编剧也对我这么说过，我当时觉得这是你能进行的最有效率的分手了，差不多吧，你知道的，我们总是面临时间问题，而且我真的不想看凯蒂和你之间出现冗长的场景，
you know, just wasn't about that. And it seemed to me he was motivated to be brusque and, you know, Yeah. He was, he was really upset. He was hurting. He was hurting and he just sort of lashed out. I didn't think it needed to be long. I thought it was perfect, but I also love, and this is something we talked about a lot,
你知道的，重点不在这里。而且在我看来，他被激怒了，所以表现得有些唐突，而且，是的。他当时真的很难过。他在受伤。他在受伤，他只是有点情绪失控。我并不觉得这需要拍得很长。我觉得这样完美极了，但我也很喜欢，这是我们经常讨论的事情，
Greg, is that these characters are flawed people. They're not perfect people. So they're going to have moments like Pam was petty. I think Pam has been petty and my character is certainly, we've talked about my character is certainly, you know, not the nicest person and. You went the longest being not the nicest of any character. Yes. And which was great because then when we got into season nine and I was kind of casting
格雷格，那就是这些角色都是有瑕疵的人。他们不是完美的人。所以他们会有这样的时刻，比如帕姆曾经很小家子气。我觉得帕姆也有过小家子气的时候，而我的角色当然，我们讨论过，我的角色肯定，你知道的，不是最nice的人，而且。你保持了最长时间不是任何角色里最nice的。是的。而这太棒了，因为后来当我们进入第九季，我开始为第九季的故事走向物色
about for what the arc of season nine should be, it was like, well, there's only one character left who hasn't warmed up at all. Let's put Angela through hell this year and let her soften just a smidge that deserve a happy ending. Yeah. Um, so then we have a scene where we see that Captain Jack and Meredith are sneaking away to make out, get it on something. Meredith is going to come back later without a shirt on and just a life preserver letter
方向时，就觉得，好吧，只剩下一个完全没有变温暖的角色了。今年让我们把安吉拉置于水深火热之中，让她稍微软化一点，值得一个快乐的结局吧。是的。嗯，然后我们有一个场景，我们看到杰克船长和梅雷迪思偷偷溜出去亲热，搞在一起什么的。梅雷迪思后来回来时没穿衬衫，只穿着她爸爸给她写的救生衣。
her dad wrote her. Do you remember that letter that said, dear Kate, stop taking your clothes off. Thanks, dad. Yes. Well, this gives Michael the opening to take the microphone and really start his presentation, which he does by announcing that the ship is sinking. Most of the people don't realize that this is a metaphor, passengers panic and a man jumps overboard.
你还记得那封信吗，上面写着，亲爱的凯特，别再脱衣服了。谢谢，爸爸。是的。嗯，这给迈克尔提供了一个拿起麦克风并真正开始他的演讲的机会，他是通过宣布船正在下沉来开始的。大多数人没有意识到这是一个比喻，乘客们陷入恐慌，一个男人跳进海里。
JT wrote in to ask who was the actual person who jumped in the water and a lot of people are asking what happened to that person. Yes. So that was one of the non-Dunder Mifflin people on the boat. And as I recall, he was not supposed to jump off the boat. As I recall, I mean, I may be blowing this because it was a while ago, but I, I think there was a little bit of shock that one of the extras jumped off the boat in that take. And I think we were probably not supposed to let him jump off the boat.
JT写信来问真正跳进水里的是谁，很多人都在问那个人后来怎么了。是的。所以那是船上非邓德米弗林的员工之一。据我回忆，他是不应该跳下船的。据我回忆，我可能把这事夸大了，因为那是很久以前的事了，但我，我想当时大家有点震惊，因为在那个镜头里有个群众演员跳下了船。而且我想我们可能本来不应该让他跳下船的。
Well, on the DVD commentary, Greg, you said he really jumped out of the window into the freezing cold water. And you said that you always felt bad that there is no, like, this person jumped in the water. It wasn't on camera. It wasn't on camera. He didn't jump in a boat. He didn't jump in a boat.
嗯，在DVD评论音轨里，格雷格，你说他真的是从窗户跳进冰冷刺骨的水里的。你说你总是感到遗憾，因为没有，比如，这个人跳进了水里。那不在镜头里。那不在镜头里。他没有跳进船里。他没有跳进船里。
He had to be fished out of the water. There could have been just a rubber dingy there. I believe it only happened the one time. Yeah. I think so. I think he went, I think he may have either misinterpreted some direction or he just was super enthusiastic. I don't, I don't, I have a slight memory of that being a little too gorilla.
他得被从水里捞出来。那里本可以放一艘橡皮艇的。我相信那只发生过那一次。是的。我想是的。我想他可能要么误解了某些导演指令，要么就是超级热情。我不，我不，我依稀记得那有点太游击作风了。
That's like Kent, Kent was out there running that shot. Kent was in the boat that was supposed to catch him, but he went and took the shot. Yeah. Well, I loved at, so this is around 17 minutes, 34 seconds for my time code people. But I loved that the Dunder Mifflin employees know immediately that there's no emergency. And like, even like Kevin and Angela, like we are in a booth together, Oscar, I guess is off somewhere being snarky. And we're like, no, no, guys, no, no, there's nothing, but you're trying to calm it down.
这就好像肯，肯当时在那里负责那个镜头。肯当时在应该接住他的船上，但他却去拍了那个镜头。是的。嗯，我喜欢在，所以这对于我的时间码粉丝来说大约是17分34秒。但我喜欢邓德米弗林员工立刻就知道根本没有紧急情况。而且就像，甚至像凯文和安吉拉，比如我们一起在一个卡座里，奥斯卡我猜不知道在哪儿刻薄呢，而我们在说，不，不，伙计们，不，不，什么事也没有，但你在试图平息它。
Yeah. Yeah. And you pan across all the different Dunder Mifflin employees and they're like, Oh God, here we go. But the rest of the boat doesn't know. Well, this, oh, go ahead. What are you going to say? Well, I'm just saying this was leading up to him being handcuffed on the roof.
是的。是的。然后镜头扫过所有不同的邓德米弗林员工，他们一副“哦天哪，又来了”的表情。但船上的其他人并不知道。嗯，这个，哦，你接着说。你本来要说什么？嗯，我只是说这是在为他被手铐拷在屋顶上做铺垫。
Yes. Yes. And the kind of secret impetus for this whole episode was that, you know, we had come on the air in the first season and we were given, you know, six episodes and we didn't do a great job in the ratings. And there was a lot of question whether we'd get invited back. And so at one point in between the seasons, Kevin Riley said, come in and, you know, pitch me a new take on the show.
是的。是的。而这一集背后的秘密动力其实是，你知道的，我们在第一季播出了，我们只拿到了，你知道的，六集，而且我们在收视率上表现得不是很好。有很多关于我们是否能被邀请回来的疑问。所以在一季之间的某个时候，凯文·赖利说，来吧，你知道的，向我推销一个关于节目的新构思。
What, like, why should I bring you guys back? Oh my gosh, pressure. There was a lot of pressure. And so I had initially kind of thought that the office was such a special, unique show which I had so much respect for that I wouldn't change very much on it. And I realized that I needed to change something. And I had some experience with this with King of the Hill in making Hank likable, the leader of King of the Hill.
什么，比如，我凭什么把你们带回来？哦天哪，压力山大。当时压力很大。所以最初我有点认为办公室是一部如此特殊、独特的剧集，我对其充满了敬意，以至于我不会对它做太多改变。后来我意识到我必须做出一些改变。我在《山丘之王》里让汉克变得讨人喜欢、成为领袖时有过这方面的经验。
And there was, he has certain qualities that were invented to keep him likable. And so I was like, oh, this isn't really that different. I, you know, because Michael has some negative qualities and I just got to find a way to give him some stories that are going to warm him up. And so I wrote out a bunch of story ideas somewhere, like in probably in Norm's, no, we weren't at Norm's yet. That was my go-to place in the mornings on Sherman Way and Woodman. But yeah, so I was in some, you know, coffee shop and I wrote down a bunch of moments that
而且，他身上有某些特质是为了让他保持讨人喜欢而被发明的。所以我当时想，哦，这其实并没有那么不同。我，你知道的，因为迈克尔有一些负面特质，我只需要找到一种方法给他安排一些能让他变暖心的故事。所以我把一堆故事点写在某处，可能在诺姆餐厅，不，我们当时还没去诺姆餐厅呢。那是早晨我在谢尔曼路和伍德曼街的最爱去处。但不管怎样，我当时在某个，你知道的，咖啡馆里，我写下了一堆我
I thought would warm him up. And one of them was that, for instance, that the, you know, that even though the staff finds him irritating, they'll back him against an outsider. So that was like the end of Dundee's. And you know, one of them was like, he should be good at his job, which happened in the client. And he actually was a good salesperson. And this one was that he should give a piece of really good advice to somebody that the
认为能让他变暖心的时刻。其中之一就是，比如说，你知道的，尽管员工们觉得他很烦人，但他们会在面对外人时支持他。所以这就是《邓迪奖》的结局。你知道的，其中一个情节是，他应该很擅长自己的工作，这发生在《客户》那一集里。他实际上是一个优秀的销售人员。而这个情节是，他应该给某人提供一些非常好的建议，让
audience was going to be happy that that advice was transferred, you know, and you'd be like, yeah, good for you, Michael. And so it was sort of all about him telling Jim to never give up on the top of that thing. BFD. Yeah, BFD, right? Engaged ain't married. But that's what the audience wanted to see. You know, Jim was so sad.
观众会为这个建议被传达而感到高兴，然后你会觉得，干得好，迈克尔。所以这基本上都是关于他在那东西的顶端告诉吉姆永远不要放弃。BFD。是的，BFD对吧？订婚了又没结婚。但这正是观众想看到的。你知道的，吉姆太难过了。
You wanted somebody to give him some hope and keep this Jim Pamp thing going. And so Michael kind of stepped in and I took the never, ever, ever give up from actually the Winston Churchill speech, which, you know, this is so nerdy of me, right? This is perfectly you. Yeah, but like I always choke up at the speeches of Winston Churchill in World War II and, you know, fight him on the beaches, you know, and he has something where he says, never, ever, ever, ever give in, you know, and I was like, that's cool, I'm going to crib that for Michael.
你希望有人能给他一些希望，让这个吉姆和帕姆的故事继续下去。所以迈克尔某种程度上介入了，而我“永远、永远、永远不要放弃”这句话实际上是摘自温斯顿·丘吉尔的演讲，你知道的，我这人太书呆子气了，对吧？这完全符合你的风格。是的，但每当听到温斯顿·丘吉尔在二战中的演讲时，我总是忍不住哽咽，你知道的，在海滩上与他们战斗，你知道的，他有一次说，永远、永远、永远不要屈服，你知道的，当时我就想，这太酷了，我要把它借用到迈克尔身上。
Well, it worked and it also worked for me, like on a different level for Michael, like it works for Jim, but for Michael, the whole episode, he just wanted someone to feel inspired by him. Yeah. You know? So when Roy announces the engagement, he was like, is this because of the talk you and I had? And he goes, no, Captain Jack.
嗯，这起作用了，而且对我来说也起作用了，在迈克尔身上达到了不同的层面，这对吉姆管用，但对于迈克尔来说，这一整集里，他只是希望有人能从他身上受到启发。是的。你知道吗？所以在罗伊宣布订婚时，他说，这是因为你和我谈过的话吗？然后他说，不，是杰克船长。
And he's like, ugh. So you see like Jim's appreciation in this moment and I feel like Michael feels it. And I'm like, oh, Michael got one person. Yeah, it was great because the two plots kind of intersect there for a moment. And when Jim first walks up to Michael, as an audience member, I'm thinking, oh gosh, this is the worst person for him to be around right now. I know, I know. He is so vulnerable.
然后他一副“呃”的表情。所以你能看到吉姆在这个时刻的感激之情，我觉得迈克尔感受到了。然后我就想，哦，迈克尔成功影响了一个人。是的，这太棒了，因为这两条情节线在那里交织在了一起。当吉姆第一次走向迈克尔时，作为观众，我在想，哦天哪，现在是他最不应该待在一起的人。我知道，我知道。他太脆弱了。
This is bad. And then it turns into what it is and it's perfect, perfect. After a few of those, Michael starts to get to be a better lead. Well guys, we did it. We did it. Greg, thank you so much. I want to give a plug. You have a new show coming up called Upload, which premieres on Amazon Prime this April.
这太糟糕了。然后它变成了现在的样子，完美，完美。在经历了其中几次之后，迈克尔开始成为一个更好的领导者了。好吧，伙计们，我们做到了。我们做到了。格雷格，非常感谢你。我想做个宣传。你有一个即将上映的新剧叫《上载新生》，将于今年4月在亚马逊Prime上首播。
This is crazy. This is the first show that you have written since you wrote The Finale of the Office. That's correct. I've been working on this for so long. It's kind of ridiculous. We had our strike in 2008 and I was, this was my sort of idea to write a book like a sci-fi book. And then we went back to work.
这太疯狂了。这是你自《办公室》大结局以来编写的第一部剧集。没错。我为这个筹备了太久了。这有点荒谬。我们在2008年罢工，当时我是，这算是我的一种构思，想写一本书，一本科幻书。然后我们又回去工作了。
And so, you know, it was gestating for a long time and it's sort of a romance, very intense and it's set in the future. And I am in. I am in. I love sci-fi. I am so in. Well, it's got a very kind of accessible, more Harry Pottery than like on a spaceship kind of deal.
所以，你知道的，它酝酿了很长时间，这有点像是一部浪漫剧，非常紧张，故事背景设定在未来。我加入。我加入了。我喜欢科幻。我太加入了。嗯，它有一种非常平易近人的感觉，比那种在飞船上的科幻更像是哈利·波特风格的处理方式。
And yeah, and I anyway, so I had been working on it pretty much since the office went down, which is ridiculous, but I wrote it. I sold it to HBO. It was there for a couple of years and then it went over to Amazon and we shot it in Vancouver at the beginning of the year. And yeah, it's finally coming out. I can't wait to see it. I love all of this.
而且，不管怎样，自从《办公室》结束之后，我基本上就一直在创作它，这太荒谬了，但我把它写出来了。我把它卖给了HBO。它在那里呆了几年，然后转到了亚马逊，我们在今年年初在温哥华拍摄了它。然后，是的，它终于要上映了。我迫不及待想看到了。我太喜欢这一切了。
These are like some of my favorite movies. And it's a comedy. Yeah, it's funny too. It's a comedy. It's like a lot of stuff. It's a comedy. There's it's basically there's this idea that in the future, medical imagery will get much better and virtual reality and it will become possible if you're in an accident and you
这些就像是我最喜欢的电影中的一些。而且这是一部喜剧。是的，它也很好笑。这是一部喜剧。这就像有很多元素。它是一部喜剧。基本上有这样一个概念，在未来，医学影像技术会变得好得多，虚拟现实也是，如果你出了事故，并且你
get to the hospital in time to have your brain scanned and then you can be uploaded. It's called upload into a virtual reality hotel that's run by all the big tech companies. So the six big tech companies that have things like Alexa and Siri, they have programmed these luxurious sort of virtual hotels along the lines of different themes. So like the Facebook one is like a casino and the Apple one is like, you know, some sort of beachy kind of resort. And the one that he ends up being uploaded in is like this mountain hotel on a lake. And anyway, that's now did his body die?
及时赶到医院，你的大脑就可以被扫描，然后你就可以被上载。这就叫上载，上载到一个由各大科技公司运营的虚拟现实酒店中。所以拥有像Alexa和Siri这样产品的六大科技公司，他们根据不同的主题编程设计了这些奢华的虚拟酒店。所以像Facebook的主题就像是一个赌场，而苹果的主题就像是，你知道的，某种海滩度假村。而他最终被上载到的那个地方就像是山地湖畔酒店。不管怎样，现在他的身体死了吗？
And then he's uploaded. Do we know? Is that a spoiler? No, his brain was scanned. No, I know. But I'm saying is that's your head. It burns your head off when when the scan when the scan happened. So you have died in the real world.
然后他被上载了。我们知道吗？那是剧透吗？不，他的大脑被扫描了。不，我知道。但我是说那是你的头。当扫描发生时，它把你的头烧掉了。所以你在现实世界中已经死了。
And now you live out the information exists and it's digitally presented in a piece of software so that you think you're still alive. I love it. I love it. Upload on Amazon. I can't wait in April. So yeah, guys, if you want more from the man who gave you the office, you have to check out Upload.
现在你依靠存在的信息生活，它以数字形式呈现在一段软件中，让你以为自己还活着。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。亚马逊的《上载新生》。我迫不及待地想在4月看到了。所以，是的，伙计们，如果你想要更多来自带给你《办公室》的这个男人的作品，你们必须去看看《上载新生》。
Yay. Thanks, Greg. Thank you so much. What a pleasure. Thank you. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Irwulf, Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher, our sound engineer is Sam Peefer.
耶。谢谢，格雷格。非常感谢。太荣幸了。谢谢。谢谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Irwulf制作，珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利出品。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·皮弗。
And our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of the show and our bonus episodes Candy Bag, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。想要收听本节目的无广告版本以及我们的额外节目《糖果袋》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用一个月的Stitcher Premium，请使用优惠码OFFICE。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。